Harry Kersh: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out
the biggest differences
between the UK and US McDonald's.
This is what a small drink
looks like in the UK.
Joe Avella: This is a US small.
Harry: This is what a
medium drink looks like.
Joe: This is a US medium.
Harry: And this is a large.
Joe: [grunts] And this is a US large.
Harry: So, with our McNuggets in the UK,
the default adult sizes on the menu
are a box of six,
a box of nine,
or a share box of 20.
Joe: Nuggets. You can get a box of four,
or you can get a six piece,
or 10.
20, for "sharing."
Or...ahh.
40.
And according to the three
McDonald's in the area,
they don't have 20 or 40 boxes,
they just do them in increments of 10,
but this is on the menu.
Harry: In the UK, we got
three sizes of fries.
These are our small
fries in the paper bag.
Joe: Here is the small fry.
Harry: These are our medium
fries in the iconic carton.
Joe: Here is the medium fry.
Harry: And then these are our large fries.
Joe: And here is the large fry.
Harry: So, we couldn't find
the exact weight measurement
for these fries online,
so what we're gonna do
is weigh them ourselves.
Just out of curiosity,
gonna bring our trusty
friend, the scales, back,
and we're gonna weigh the Big Mac
and see if there is
any difference in size.
I'm not sure there will
be, but let's find out.
Joe: Hang on, hang on, hang on.
Harry: So, while McDonald's
fries might look and taste
pretty similar in the UK and the US,
in the UK we only have three ingredients,
which is oil, salt, and potatoes.
Joe: The McDonald's
french fries in America
have way more ingredients.
These fries are made
from potatoes, obviously;
a vegetable oil, which
has canola oil, corn oil,
soybean oil, hydrogeni...
hydrogenitated...genitated?
Producer: Hydrogenated.
Joe: Ha! Thank you.
Hydrogenated soybean
oil, natural beef flavor,
dextrose, sodium aspid...phosphitate?
Phosphifi...phos...phiupp...pyrophosphate,
pyrophosphate, sodium acid pyrophosphate,
which is used to maintain the color.
Are they that much of a different
color than the ones in the UK?
Is it worth it?
Can we get a side-by-side comparison?
Are they that much more bright yellow
we need to put sodium acid pyrophosphate
or whatever it's called in it?
Salt, and I should mention
that a natural beef flavor
contains hydrolyzed
wheat and hydrolyzed milk
as a starting ingredient, and of course
I have no idea what that means.
Harry: So, the biggest calorie
difference in a Big Mac
actually comes from the sauce.
In the US they've got about
40 more calories than we do in the UK.
We're not sure if this is
because there's more sauce
or because the ingredients list in the UK
is just a little bit more simple.
Joe: Our sauce is made of soybean oil,
sweet relish, which is
made of diced pickles,
sugar, high-fructose corn syrup,
distilled vinegar, salt, corn syrup,
all right, two types of corn syrup,
xanthan gum,
hang on.
Calcium chloride, spice extractives?
Water. All right, I've heard of that.
Egg yolks, distilled vinegar,
spices, onion powder, salt,
propylene glycol alginate?
Garlic powder; vegetable protein,
which has hydrolyzed corn, soy, and wheat;
sugar; caramel color; turmeric;
extractives of paprika; and, of course,
soy...lechithen.
Leechithen.
Lecithin.
I don't know which one it is.
Harry: So, if you are
trying to eat healthily
at McDonald's, it might actually be
the drinks that you have to look out for.
Joe: That's nothing, guys.
Our chocolate shake? 840 calories.
That's as many calories as
two cheeseburgers and one hamburger.
Harry: So, what does that all mean?
If you were to walk into a UK McDonald's
and order yourself a large
Big Mac meal with a milkshake,
it would be around 1,400 calories.
Joe: And if you were to
get the large Big Mac meal
with a chocolate shake in America,
the total here is 1,870 calories.
So that's 1,870 calories,
the daily calorie allowance
for an American dude
is 2,500, OK.
So you have 630 left.
One McNugget is 55 calories, right?
So you could also have 11 more nuggets,
and there you go, that's
all you need for the day.
Harry: Here's everything you can only get
at a UK McDonald's.
So, here we've got the
Veggie Deluxe burger,
which is a veggie burger that's served
with some mayo and some lettuce.
Here we've got a Chicken Legend,
which is a chicken burger,
again served with mayo and lettuce.
Joe: Chicken Legend, I don't
even know what that is.
Not gonna catch on.
That can stay in the UK.
Harry: We have a range of wraps
that you can get in the UK.
We have a wrap of the day.
Here we've got the fajita
crisp, which is some chicken,
along with some veg and
some spicy fajita sauce.
Here we've got some Veggie Dippers.
These were actually introduced
at part of Veganuary
in 2020 in the UK, but
they're stuck on the menu.
So, these are Vegan Society-approved,
and they're sort of like a
fried-bean-patty sort of thing.
Joe: [sighs] Like, pick a more
unappetizing thing to get at McDonald's.
Veggie Dippers.
Harry: And then finally we've
got some Mozzarella Dippers,
which are just kind of
mozzarella sticks, really.
Joe: Well, sucks to be in the UK,
'cause everything you see
right here is USA only, baby.
Haha, USA only!
So, I'm gonna talk about
the coffee drinks real fast.
Here in the US, we have
all the same coffee drinks
they do in the UK, but every coffee drink
has an iced version and also a caramel
and/or French vanilla
and/or mocha version,
depending on what you're getting.
So, we in the US, of
course, have more variety.
Shamrock Shake.
The Shamrock Shake is, like,
it's like vanilla and mint shake.
Strawberry Sundae.
This has recently been
discontinued in the UK.
Sorry, guys.
Still got it in the US.
My favorite as a kid, the Caramel Sundae.
Fruit and Yogurt Parfait,
maybe it's healthy,
I have no idea, probably not.
Those were the cold items I
wanted to get out of the way
as they slowly melt under these lights.
Got a lot more to go through.
Harry, bear with me here, buddy.
Buttermilk Crispy Chicken Sandwich.
Yo, I think this was introduced
when the chicken-sandwich
wars were really heating up
when Chick-fil-A started taking over.
Let's see what's under the hood.
Look at that. Look at this.
Quarter Pounder with Cheese Deluxe.
This is your fancy Quarter
Pounder with Cheese.
This is for Sunday dinner.
When you have company over.
Ah, there's so much.
Sausage Breakfast Burrito.
Even after it's, for a while, it's, like,
still, like, glowing yellow. [laughs]
Now, these are the Buttermilk
Crispy Chicken Tenders.
These smell amazing. I wanna
just bite into these so bad.
I wanna just take a big bite.
Wanna talk about sauces real quick.
OK, I'm at McDonald's, and I
go get me one of everything.
I've heard from Harry and
the team over in the UK
that some of these they don't have,
including sweet 'n sour, honey mustard,
what else don't you guys have?
I don't think you guys have
ranch either, or buffalo.
I gotta say, though, the
sauces are everything.
Harry: We've got a couple of sauces that
are kind of unique to the UK as well.
We've got a sweet curry dipping sauce,
and then we've also got
a salsa dip as well,
which I didn't know existed until today.
Joe: Oh, yes, Donut Sticks.
These Donut Sticks also come
with a chocolate dipping sauce.
Another thing I'm certain
they don't have in the UK.
Yo ho ho ho ho ho ho!
Breakfast is served!
Look at this. Oh, yeah.
Who's ready to start the day?
[claps] It's McGriddle talk.
[audience applause]
[jazzy music]
So, for those of you in the UK
who don't know what a McGriddle is,
the United States McDonald's
had this genius idea:
What if we took breakfast sandwiches,
replaced the buns,
and made them pancakes
and somehow injected
some sort of syrup
flavor into the pancakes?
And the McGriddle was born.
And, I have to say, they're fantastic.
This one right here, the bacon,
egg, and cheese McGriddle.
This is the sausage.
Yeah? Hi!
Hey, hey.
This is the sausage, egg,
and cheese McGriddle.
American food engineering at its finest.
Look at that.
In the UK, you guys call
biscuits cookies. Here...no.
So, in the UK, biscuits are cookies,
what we call cookies.
In the US, biscuits are what we call...
uh...
I don't know what else you can call them.
Like, you bake them, and
they're from the South,
and they're dry, and I
don't know what they are.
Much like the McGriddles,
we have a version of
every breakfast sandwich
that instead of the regular
bun bread, it's biscuits.
Not the cookie biscuits
like you guys have.
These biscuits.
Harry: Joe, you were so close on the whole
cookie-biscuit thing.
What you guys call biscuits,
we would actually kind of call scones,
or scones, depending on where you're from,
and the thought of putting breakfast food
in between them is kinda weird.
They're usually reserved for
cream and jam for an afternoon tea.
Joe: Last, and,
in my opinion, least,
is this thing.
The Southwest Grilled Chicken Salad.
Producer: Yeah.
Joe: Oh ho ho ho ho.
Harry: Can I eat now?
Yeah? Yeah? K, cool.
I don't care how many calories,
it's just really good.
Mm-hmm.
Joe Avella From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out
all the differences
between McDonald's in India
and the US .
This is "Food Wars."
Drinks in McDonald's
India come in three sizes:
regular, medium, and large.
Drinks in the McDonald's
in the US, four sizes:
extra small, small, medium, and large.
Time to keep 'em honest.
Lost a couple drops. 26, 27 fluid ounces.
Whoo!
Hm.
Fries in India come in three sizes:
regular, medium, and large.
In America, our fries come
in four sizes, I think.
We have a small, kids,
or kids, small --
I can't tell the difference either --
medium, and large.
The medium and large
come in these really cool
new packaging where you can
just open it up like that
and it's nice and easy to share.
It's a little plate.
Good job, McDonald's. Very innovative.
But now it's time to measure
and see how much we're really getting.
Joe: First things first, the large.
175 grams.
Obviously it's different
per scoops or whatever.
Yeah, let's go here.
This one, almost exactly 100 grams.
This one,
80 grams.
Fry math, hang on.
This is, like ...
yep, there you go.
That's a 20-gram difference right there.
So, you tell me, internet.
Is the kids and the small different sizes?
I don't think they are.
"Food Wars" is on it! We're on it, baby!
What about McNuggets?
Here in India, you can
order them in three sizes:
six pieces, nine pieces, and 20 pieces.
They gave it to us in
two boxes of 10 each.
Oh, is that it, India? Cute.
Our McNuggets start at four,
then you got six,
10,
20,
and not to be outdone,
booyah, 40 McNuggets.
All the mathheads watching
will be quick to point out
that that is double India's
largest nugget option.
The only burger that
India shares with the US
is the McChicken, the humble McChicken.
Not even gonna bother
with the analog scale now.
Boop!
149 grams.
Ah, just so frustrating.
Just one more gram and
it would be perfect.
With the paper? I mean, we'll do this and
shave off an eighth of an ounce.
Our McChicken weighs 140 grams.
Here is everything you'll find on the menu
at McDonald's India that you
will not find in the USA.
And here's all the McDonald's menu items
from the US you won't find in India.
Here in India, we can't really recreate
the iconic McDonald's Big Mac
because it's made from a beef patty,
and to keep to the religious sentiments
of Hindus and even Muslims,
we don't serve beef or pork
in a lot of fast-food restaurants.
We have something called
the chicken Maharaja Mac.
As you can see, it's got
three buns, two patties,
a lot of cheese and mayonnaise,
some tomatoes, onions, lettuce.
Lettuce try it now.
[ba-dum tish]
Oh, my God.
That is truly a Maharaja Mac.
If you're wondering, a raja is a king,
and a maharaja is like an emperor.
So this is clearly our
answer to the Big Mac.
Now let's taste the veg Maharaja Mac.
I think it's actually
a very cool challenge
that a lot of fast-food restaurants here
have had to adapt to the Indian palate,
as well as sensibilities of food.
We have come up with such
cool, iconic fast food
that you won't get
anywhere else in the world.
Like, look at this! This is outrageous!
There's no way to eat
this without being messy.
There's literally no way.
Mm!
Oh, my God. That's really good.
Yes to all that, looks really good.
Because of India's lack of beef,
all the American beef options
are technically exclusives.
All right.
Big Mac.
There it is, just brimming with stuff.
My go-to for, like, 20 years.
I still get it occasionally.
The classic McDonald's hamburger.
Beef patty, ketchup, and mustard.
Of course, you can get it with cheese. Hi.
You can upgrade to a double
cheeseburger or a McDouble.
What's the difference, you ask?
I'm not sure either.
So let's start with the
double cheeseburger.
Look at that. Look how yellow that is.
Beef, cheese, beef, cheese, toppos.
The McDouble is beef, cheese, beef.
So it's just one slice of cheese
in the middle, but not on top.
What's the price difference?
Can we get that on-screen?
And how much is a slice of cheese?
Joe's hack, get yourself a McDouble
and bring your own slice
of American cheese.
Booyah. Save yourself
this amount of money.
The problem with millennials today,
the reason you guys can't buy houses is
you're spending all
your money at Starbucks,
you're getting your double cheeseburgers
instead of a McDouble and
bringing your own cheese slice.
I mean, you guys are terrible with money!
You're eating, what, seven,
eight McDoubles a day like me, right?
And that adds up to, like,
at the end of the year, $18?
10,000 years later, that's
a down payment on a house.
What are you guys doing?
All right, next up is the
iconic McAloo tikki burger.
You take mashed potato, and
you fry it in breadcrumbs,
and you get this really delicious cutlet.
Here in India, they
adapted it into this burger
with a very special sauce,
some tomato, and chopped onions.
Mm. It's just so classic.
They nailed this burger.
Next up, there is a Mexican McAloo tikki,
which I assume has some
stereotypical Mexican ingredients
and flavors like jalapeño.
Yes! Jalapeño.
Mm, nice.
It's way more spicy. Good twist.
Next up, they have a McEgg burger.
McEgg. McEgg, McEgg.
I don't know why I did that.
Let's see what that looks like.
Ugh!
Sorry.
I did not expect ... pesto?
Next up is a chicken kebab burger.
Every time an Indian
fast-food chain tries to adapt
an Indian special food into a burger,
I take it with a pinch of salt
because this is not what
we're used to seeing
when we think of kebabs,
but I'm going to try it,
and let's see what happens.
Mm.
It's very, very dry.
Patty has almost a
cardboard-y taste to it.
I wouldn't put those flavors together
if I was thinking kebab.
McCardboard tikki, maybe? No? OK.
That's a bit harsh. I'm sorry.
Next up is the McVeggie,
which is the vegetarian
counterpart to our McChicken.
If I had to eat this
versus the chicken one,
I would not be upset at all.
Really good.
Next up, we have two "American" burgers:
the American Cheese Supreme veg
and the American Cheese Supreme chicken.
My hunch for what makes them American
is that they will have a
nice big square of cheese
and they will not be spicy at all.
Except they have a lot
of jalapeños on them.
Joe, let me know if this
constitutes "American."
That's American cheese, my man.
That's what makes it American.
I don't know about those
other toppings, but,
yeah, it sounds about right.
All right, so this is what
the McDonald's website
says is in this burger.
"Whole-wheat buns
sourced from Maharashtra,
tangy jalapeños from Karnataka,
shredded onions grown
in local Indian farms,
and cheese from Amaravati, also in India."
Quite close to home, this burger.
Currently, this would
probably be my favorite order,
a McSpicy chicken, and
there's the vegetarian option,
which is a McSpicy paneer,
which is just leaking lettuce.
For those of you who
don't know what paneer is,
it's basically cottage cheese.
We love our paneer.
We put it in curries, we eat
it plain, we put it in kebabs.
It is so delicious. Let's try this.
Mm. It has just the right kick,
and it goes really well with the paneer.
Fair warning, while this
may have a light kick
of spice for us, it might
be a hard kick for you.
So, take everything with
a pinch of chili powder.
Gonna move up to something
called the Quarter Pounder,
and that's, like, their big burger.
So you can get a Quarter
Pounder with cheese.
Here it is.
I mean, it looks fake, right?
Like, "Just kidding, it's cake!"
Or the new one is, "It's
actually a candle!"
And then you can get a Quarter
Pounder with cheese deluxe.
More veggies on it, all
the junk that I brush off.
You can upgrade to a double
Quarter Pounder with cheese.
Let's take a look. Oh, man.
Look how thick this is!
And then you can get that
same double with bacon.
Yeah!
Oh, man. Skimping on the bacon. Guys!
What we lack in beef
burgers we make up for
in gourmet burgers.
That's right. Here at McDonald's India,
we have our own collection of
chef's special gourmet burgers.
Delicious.
And I think this is a rolling menu.
I think they introduce new
things from time to time.
The buns themselves
look a lot more gourmet.
You know, there's a nice
rift down the middle.
Kind of looks like a butt, but that's OK.
We're not gonna concentrate on that.
First up, we have triple
cheese American veg burger
and triple cheese American chicken burger.
Same thing. Cheese, jalapeño,
some sauce, lettuce,
simple chicken patty, gourmet bun.
Does this scream "American" to you?
Next up, Cheese Lava American veg burger
and Cheese Lava American chicken burger,
again with American
and again with the strange relation
of food to volcanoes and lava.
OK.
This burger is very spicy.
This qualifies as a
volcano product, for sure.
Congratulations, McDonald's.
The lava in the title
of this burger works.
The McSpicy chicken premium, though,
has an egg patty inside of it.
Mm-mm.
Mm, that's pretty good.
I just feel so existential right now.
Imagine sitting here at this table
and just tasting every single
burger on a McDonald's menu.
Amazing.
But also, s---.
We also have some exclusive wrap options.
We have Big Spicy paneer
and Big Spicy chicken.
I think this is the same
McSpicy chicken patty,
and it's wrapped around a tortilla,
which is actually way
closer to an Indian chapati
than most other fast-food restaurants.
It doesn't feel as synthetic.
Our McDonald's in the US
had wraps for a brief period of time.
One day they were gone. Nobody noticed.
Yeah, you guys got some chicken
stuff that we don't have,
but we got a few of our own.
More recently than you think,
they finally introduced
their chicken sandwich
to an already-crowded
chicken-sandwich market,
and that is of course their
crispy chicken sandwich,
and this thing is fantastic.
It's one of the best ones.
They were late to the game,
and they kind of took
it over, in my opinion.
And what I like about it,
it's simple. Look at this.
You just got crispy
chicken, pickles that suck.
It's baller. It tastes great.
Like it a little spicy, India?
It probably doesn't
compare to what you guys
are rocking in India but, you know,
this one has a little nice heat to it.
Pickles, sauce.
Want to take it up a notch?
Gotta go deluxe.
The cool crispness of the vegetables
just clash so well with the spicy sauce.
It's good. It's good.
Nikhil, say the word,
and I'm putting one in
the post for you tomorrow.
So when it arrives in three weeks,
you can throw it out.
Now we're getting into
exclusive side dishes.
Here in India, we have these add-ons.
No. 1, the veg pizza McPuff.
This is one of the most
delicious things we have here.
It's basically a pizza Hot Pocket.
Masala wedges. These are potato wedges
with classic Indian masala flavor to them.
Ooh, boy.
Masalas are basically what we use
to spice and flavor dishes,
and they consist primarily
of ground-up spices
like cardamom, cloves,
red chilies, Kashmiri chilies.
You go to every Indian home, the mums,
the grandmums will have
their own random, you know,
masala mix that they
use and that's guarded
and treasured in their family, forever.
Next up, we have cheesy masala wedges.
They're also serving a
classic cup of boiled corn,
which is so unique, and they
give you a side of Amul butter.
Guys, Amul butter is part of our culture.
Makhan. Makhan!
This is probably going to be
the most delicious bite of the day.
I love corn.
Next up, chicken strips.
They come in packs of two, three, or five.
Cheesy nugget veg bites.
Yeah, this is just a vegetarian version
of the chicken nuggets,
and it's got some corn, some tomato.
Mm, it's OK.
Next, we have the double cheese McMuffin.
And lastly, we have Mexican cheesy fries.
On the McDonald's India website,
one British customer said
that these Mexican cheesy
fries are "the real deal."
I have no idea how a
British person can say
that Mexican cheesy
fries are the real deal,
but anytime a British person says
that another culture's
food is "the real deal,"
it puts a little fear in
our small Indian hearts.
Yeah those fries look like ass.
And the next exclusive side
that we have is apple slices.
Cut 'em up, put 'em in a plastic bag.
'Bout to get saucy. That's
right, ladies and gentlemen.
Sauce talk.
Thank you.
Spicy Buffalo.
Not that good.
We got a tangy barbecue.
Ooh.
Much better.
Mm. Honey mustard.
Tastes like salad dressing.
Sweet and sour.
I would tie it with the tangy barbecue
because it's so different,
so we'll keep these guys
same tier.
Ranch, I don't know.
America, we love our ranch.
Ranch is just OK.
That's right, I said it. Ranch is just OK.
Oh, and all ranch tastes the same. Yeah.
And finally, honey.
How do you like that?
Honey's the best one.
And all that money, all that energy,
all that time creating all these recipes,
trying to sway the American mind,
and you got beat by a bunch of bees.
Power to the bees!
We have one exclusive spice mix
as well as one exclusive
sauce here in India.
We have chili sauce, which
is pretty straightforward.
It's chili sauce.
But let me tell you about
peri-peri spice mix.
So, McDonald's launched
this in 2013 here in India,
and it was so popular, there were riots
when they said they were
going to discontinue it.
And so now, it's a permanent
addition to the menu.
First, you get this shake bag,
then you grab your fries,
and then you just pour that in there.
Ah.
Boom! Oh, boy.
Can we cut to a before of the fries?
You saw how they were. Now look at these.
You can see the little flecks of spice
just adorning each fry.
Hello, it's Crystelle.
And I know Nikhil has
peri-peri McDonald's chips,
but in the UK, it is all about Nando's.
Cheeky Nando's.
Let's talk about peri-peri.
Peri means pepper. And
it's a blend of spices,
so it's got things like paprika,
ground bird's eye chili,
a bit of oregano, a pinch
of ginger and cardamom,
but it's a Portuguese spice blend.
It's funny because
obviously Nikhil mentioned
that the peri-peri fries
just blew off in India,
and it makes sense, because I'm from Goa,
which is in the south of India.
Goa was colonized by the Portuguese.
And so I really think that Indians
are accustomed to that
Portuguese taste palate,
which is why peri-peri fries
are doing so well in India.
But enough of the talking.
I want to dig into these
fries, because they look great.
Mm. Oh, this is so good.
Harry, get involved.
You're not eating chips
without me, are you?
Oh, sorry, I've already had a head start.
Harry: Cheers.
Crystelle: Cheers.
God damn, if that isn't like crack.
For the early risers,
there's plenty of
exclusive breakfast items
at the US McDonald's.
Sausage biscuit with egg.
Next one,
sausage biscuit.
I mean, they take the
egg out, so it's just ...
This, of course, is
bacon, egg, and cheese.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we've reached the point of the breakfast
where we get into the McGriddles.
I love McGriddles.
What's a McGriddle, you ask,
India? Fantastic question.
McDonald's had this genius idea
to replace the breakfast
sandwiches they already had
with pancakes.
And they also, like, inject
syrup into it somehow?
But it is a breakfast sandwich
with pancakes for buns,
and it's the best idea anyone's
ever had, anywhere, ever.
[Joe laughing]
Look at this! Look at this, look at this.
They've even got a little M on there.
This mini pancake.
I know I'm wearing the
gloves, but this one's mine.
Mm.
We have a veg McMuffin
and a sausage McMuffin.
Mm.
The sausage here in India
is not made out of pork,
like it is in the US.
Instead, it's made out of simple chicken.
Speaking of sausage, you
can get a breakfast burrito.
Bro, I could put five of
these away, easy. Easy.
If you're, like, a total drag
and you want oatmeal in
the morning, we have it.
It's about as inspiring
as you would think.
Hotcakes and sausage.
Of course, it comes with hot syrup.
This here,
the big breakfast with hotcakes.
And it's big.
A lot of eggs, kind of
wimpy-looking bacon,
got yourself two English muffins here.
And, of course, comes with a hash brown.
Potatoes. Who doesn't love 'em?
McDonald's hash brown, undefeated.
These things are so good.
India exclusive desserts.
We have a Black Forest McFlurry,
a vanilla chocolate muffin,
and a chocolate chip muffin.
It's kind of like a
McFlurry soup right now.
This would be really good when
it was actually a McFlurry.
Desserts! USA, we got 'em.
So, starting down here, very simple,
chocolate chip cookies.
This next thing, apple fritter, right?
Mm.
This right here is called a
glazed pull-apart doughnut.
Blueberry muffin.
If you've had one, you've had them all.
This is a what type of pie?
Let's see what's inside.
OK. I'm suddenly more interested. Yeah!
Guava and cream.
How about we'll call it
the cream and guava pie?
Nah, this sucks.
[Anders laughing]
I don't f--- with it.
Standard menu item, the
McDonald's apple pie.
Everyone knows about this.
I don't want a pizza version of this.
Eh! And last but not least, cinnamon roll.
Too sticky. I don't feel like eating it.
Update: It's not sticky.
It's actually [knocks on cinnamon roll].
Exclusive drinks, starting with,
we have something called
B Natural's mixed fruit juice.
Next up, we have something
that they call raw mango fruit splash.
Oh!
It's a bit too sweet.
Berry lemonade splash.
All of these come in these very unique
reusable bottles, apparently.
Next up, strawberry chiller,
green apple chiller,
and lemon chiller.
It's just flavored water.
That's exactly what it is.
It's flavored water,
and I kind of like it.
This is a mixed berry smoothie.
It's still quite sweet, but quite good.
Next up, American mud pie shake.
Mm. That's pretty yum.
Drink roulette.
Ooh, and the ice melted. Fantastic.
Dr. Pepper. Let's go!
Coke, nonexclusive. Let's go.
Sweet tea, too sweet.
Ugh, yeah. Unsweetened
tea, not sweet enough.
You guys combine.
For the kids watching,
why are you watching?
Where are your parents or supervisors?
You can get yourself apple juice, milk.
Come on, you're drinking milk?
The thought of drinking straight milk,
like, hurts my stomach.
There's also chocolate milk on the menu.
Once upon a time,
this was an iced French vanilla latte.
Now it's more of a room-temperature
French vanilla latte.
That's just OK. It's, like, really sweet.
Strawberry banana smoothie.
Yeah, I always loved getting these.
These are good.
So I'm going to assume
they're not good for me.
Exclusive hot drinks.
First off, we have strawberry green tea.
Next up, English breakfast tea
and Moroccan tea.
Next up, a flat white coffee.
India, a land where we run on chai,
and McDonald's does
not have a chai option.
Caramel macchiato,
cappuccino,
caramel latte,
a vanilla cappuccino.
The V does look like a U.
McDonald's premium roast coffee.
I'm going to hang on to this one.
In India, a chicken Maharaja
Mac will cost you 231 rupees
for just the sandwich.
That's around $3.03.
We do not have the chicken Maharaja Mac,
but we do have the Big Mac,
and a Big Mac in the US costs $4.89.
That is a 61% price increase.
Now, what if you turn this into a meal?
A McSaver Maharaja Mac combo
comes with regular fries
and a regular drink and
will cost you 356 rupees.
That is $4.67, still less than the price
of the American sandwich on its own.
But does the combo meal
make a difference in the US?
A medium Big Mac combo,
so Big Mac, medium fries, medium drink,
is $8.99.
That's a 92% cost increase,
even worse than if you just
bought the sandwich on its own.
On the Indian McDonald's menu,
you'll find a two-person meal,
which contains a chicken
Maharaja Mac, a veg Maharaja Mac,
large fries, two pizza
McPuffs, and a drink.
All of this will cost
you 681 rupees, or $8.93.
So, basically, you're
getting food for two people
for the price of one
person's meal in the US.
However, while it seems a lot cheaper
than the food in the US,
it's still very expensive
and aspirational to people over here.
Your minimum wage per hour
is equal to our daily minimum wage.
And so, yeah,
a lot of people can't really
afford this kind of food.
The English-speaking Indians that you see
in a lot of YouTube videos on the internet
aren't really a proper reflection
of the majority of people
that live in this country,
who still can't afford food like this.
So, I'm checking my privilege,
and we should all make sure we check ours.
But let's play devil's advocate.
McDonald's India has definitely included
a lot more affordable
options on their menu.
And so they are more approachable
to the average urban Indian
than other fast-food chains.
Let's compare some items
to see who has the least
healthy McDonald's food.
In the US, a McChicken
contains 400 calories,
21 grams of fat, 39 grams of carbs.
5 of those are sugar,
and 560 milligrams of sodium.
How about the Indian McChicken?
One of these contains 398 calories,
15 grams of total fat, 48 grams of carbs,
5 grams of which are sugars,
787 milligrams of sodium.
So the Indian version has
slightly fewer calories,
way lesser fats, but much
more carbs and sodium.
What if we made that a combo meal?
Well, a medium fry in the
US contains the following:
320 calories, 15 grams of total fat,
43 grams of carbs, no sugar,
and 260 milligrams of sodium.
While a medium fries in
India contains 340 calories,
17 grams of total fat, 41 grams of carbs,
0 grams of sugars,
and 256 milligrams of sodium.
And if we add the medium Coke,
that is adding 210 calories, no fat,
56 grams of carbs, 56 of those are sugar,
and 55 milligrams of sodium.
Ooh, a nice salty Coke.
We'll do the same. Here in India,
one medium Coke will
cost you 151 calories,
0 grams of fat, 38 grams of carbs,
38 grams of which are sugars,
and there are 0 grams
of sodium, but my God,
that is a lot of sugar packed in this cup.
That leaves the Indian
meal at a grand total
of 889 calories, 32 grams of fat,
127 grams of carbs,
out of which 43 grams are sugars,
and 1,043 milligrams of sodium.
Sheesh.
Which means this whole bad boy altogether
is 930 calories,
36 grams of total fat,
138 grams of carbs,
61 of those grams are sugar,
875 milligrams of sodium.
Little bit lower sodium than India,
but we got you guys beat in
calorie, fats, carbs, and sugar.
Mm, mm, mm, mm! We win. We win.
Ah!
Unfortunately for India,
the combo stats are a little misleading,
and the difference maker is the Coke,
because the American meal
has a larger portion.
If you order the Coke
Zero in both countries,
the Indian meal will actually
have a higher calorie count.
McDonald's India does
not share a full list
of their ingredients,
but there are some things
we do know about their food.
Like, did you know that McDonald's India
actually changed Indian farming practices
just so they could grow the
kind of potato that they wanted?
When they first launched in India in 1996,
McDonald's promised the government
that they would use products grown
and sourced right here in India.
But people who had eaten McDonald's abroad
realized that the fries
didn't taste quite the same.
The reason for this is
that Indian potatoes
were too small, round,
had way too much moisture
and sugar content.
And so the fries made out of
them were not long enough,
they didn't get crispy
enough, and they didn't have
that distinctive McDonald's oomph to them.
So, McDonald's partnered
with McCain Foods,
and they spent nine years
trying to perfect their potato.
They imported saplings
which had the perfect shape
and starch content that they needed.
They also chose Gujarat
as their farming location
for its climate, and they switched
from a flood irrigation
to a sprinkler system
to reduce moisture content and save water.
The result: bigger and
more starchy potatoes
that can be used to make
the McDonald's fries
that you know and love.
McDonald's in the US
mostly uses russet Burbank
or Shepody, "shep-a-tee," potatoes.
Potato me.
So, these are big enough that
the distinctive long fry,
yeah, look how long this is. Wow!
Known to be low moisture
and low sugar content.
This means they can
remain crispy when fried
and don't caramelize too fast,
so you can get a nice, even browning.
McDonald's in the US actually discloses
all of its ingredients,
so we can figure out a
few other differences.
In the US, for instance,
our mayonnaise contains egg yolk,
as does most American mayo.
Thanks to the FAQ page on
the McDonald's India website,
we found out that the
mayonnaise is eggless,
along with all of the other sauces
except for the tartar sauce.
When people describe things
as vegetarian here in India,
they typically mean it
doesn't contain egg.
Joe: From calorie count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between McDonald's in Japan and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Hey, guys, Joe from "Food Wars."
We're doing a new season.
We're comparing the US to Japan.
In order to do that, I
want to introduce you
to cohost and my man in Japan, George.
Hello, guys. I'm George.
I'm from Japan, and I like McDonald's.
So, in Japan, our McDonald's
sodas come in three sizes.
This is small.
Small.
And this is Japan's medium.
Medium.
And this one is Japan's large.
Large.
In Japan, our chicken McNuggets
come in five and 15 pieces.
Our chicken McNuggets come in
four,
six,
10,
20,
or 40 piece.
Look at all those nuggets.
Oh.
They've been sitting for a while.
Japan McDonald's fries
come in three sizes,
small, medium, and large.
In the US, you can get
your fries in four sizes,
kids, small, medium, and large.
Look at this little guy.
George: So, this is large fries,
and I'm going to weigh them.
Joe: We are going to also
weigh a large McDonald's fry.
Wow!
OK, so, so far our larges are the same.
Yeah, wow. That worked perfectly,
that thing I just did
there. Great job, Joe.
Go home.
Go!
Joe: Now let's measure
the medium. Why not?
Our mediums are smaller.
Huh. Interesting.
So, this is a Japanese Big Mac.
Ta-da!
[trumpets playing]
Oh!
So, this is a Japanese Big Mac.
Joe: This is an American Big Mac,
and we're going to weigh it as well.
Oh, we've got a heftier
Big Mac here in the US.
That's more like it.
So, in Japan, the Big Mac value set,
which is a Big Mac and medium
fries and a medium drink,
comes out to 690 yen, or $6.21.
In the US, that same meal costs $8.54,
or 948.46 Japanese yen.
That's a 37.52% increase
in price in the US.
What the heck?
So, here is everything you can only get
at Japan's McDonald's
you cannot get in the US.
And this is everything you
can get at a US McDonald's
that you cannot get in Japan.
So, we are going to start
with waffle cones, right here.
So, we got plain.
So, plain means it's,
like, rich milk taste.
And next one is strawberry.
Strawberry. Personally, I like this.
Our next one is
chocolate and almond, right there.
Mm.
It's not melting.
Good job, buddy.
So, here we've got McFloats.
So, McFloats means there is soda,
and on top of that, there is ice cream.
That's it. That's it.
And this is McFloats melon.
Ooh!
[laughs]
It's too sweet.
This is grape.
Coffee McFloats.
Mm.
And the last one,
we've got Coke McFloats.
Mm.
Oh, Joe, you definitely try this.
Yes, absolutely.
I'm trying that when I go to Japan.
That looks real good.
Let me think here.
Hang on a second.
[metal clanging]
OK.
We do not have McFloats here in the US,
so I'm going to make my own.
On the way over here,
I was looking for grape soda.
It's actually harder
to find than I thought.
Fanta's not very popular
in the United States.
But we got this.
This is Midnight Grape
Kickstart Mountain Dew.
It's grape.
Haha! Left over from
the Ben & Jerry's shoot.
This stuff is frozen. There we go.
[electric zapping]
Yeah. I'm into this.
These would do well in the US.
Our cold drinks, a little bit different.
We have two exclusive slushies
that you can't get in Japan.
One is a pink lemonade.
Strawberry watermelon.
Yeah, dude.
That looks real good.
Yes, they do have McFlurries
and ice cream in Japan,
but one McFlurry you can
get in the US is this one.
It's an M&M's McFlurry.
Sorry, it's since melted,
but it's like those mini M&M's.
I went to one of the few
McDonald's in the country
where the ice cream machine was working.
Hot caramel sundae,
and the classic
fudge sundae.
George: So, let's go with
soft drinks, right here.
Fanta grape,
and here is Fanta melon.
And this one is Japanese vegetable juice.
And there is,
I guess, more than 20
or 30 vegetables in it.
And it's good for health, for sure.
Aah.
[water running]
[chimes sound]
Mm.
We've got Qoo white grape.
Sokenbicha.
Sokenbicha is like a Japanese blended tea.
It's healthy.
And Japanese people drink
this on a daily basis.
So, next one,
we've got Earl Grey iced tea.
Let me show you.
Wait, there is something.
[beep]
There's a mosquito.
I have to make a complaint,
Japan McDonald's!
Next one, we've got
oolong tea.
So, this is not actually Japanese tea.
It's a Chinese tea
that's good for health as well.
For health, we do have
a mango pineapple smoothie
and a banana strawberry smoothie.
Smoothies have fruit in it, right?
Oh, yeah.
I can just feel the nutrients
coursing through my veins!
So, let's start with this Hawaiian menu.
This is limited.
This one right here is Cheese Loco Moco.
Ooh, it's messy.
It's a demi-glace sauce. Man.
And it's also got
round egg, right there,
beef patty, and some cheese.
I'm hungry, actually.
Mm!
Oh, this is good!
Oh!
[laughs]
This is [speaks Japanese],
which means really, really delicious.
All right, so, next one,
we've got garlic shrimp,
and it's also got interesting bun.
There is sesame on there.
And deep-fried shrimp.
Hawaiian barbecue potato and beef.
Demi-glace sauce again.
It's gonna be good.
This is called barbecue burger, right?
But I don't taste barbecue at all.
All right, so, next one,
we've got Hawaiian pancake
with triple berry sauce.
Two pancakes.
Hello!
Mm, smells so sweet. Ooh.
Let's go.
Ooh.
Too sweet.
McFizz blue Hawaii.
Wow.
It has bright blue color.
This is McFizz cassis and orange.
I would get this. I would get this.
So, congratulations,
this is the worst.
OK. Breakfast time.
This is a breakfast burrito.
Ugh.
Neon-yellow egg, Mexican-style salsa.
Not to be confused with,
what, Canadian salsa?
This is actually the same burrito
from the US-UK thing we
shot over a year ago. So.
Let's go on to these
breakfast sandwiches here.
Japan does have the McGriddles,
which are a favorite of mine,
so unfortunately we will not
be talking about those today.
Sad face.
I love you, McGriddles.
So, what they don't have,
and also the UK did not have,
were our breakfast biscuit sandwiches.
I don't know how to describe a biscuit,
other than it's dry,
it's baked.
Maybe they're made with cornmeal?
According to the internet,
this is not a scone, so there you go.
Sausage, egg, and cheese.
Our egg is like
this fluffy, folded scrambled-egg egg.
So theirs are, like, sunny-side up?
Ours are scrambled.
I can tell this was folded over.
You can see the fold lines there.
This is how we do it in the US.
Bacon, egg, and cheese.
Is there a better breakfast
combination in the world?
I don't think there is.
Then they just have a sausage,
no egg, no cheese,
just sausage and biscuit.
We have regular-sized hotcakes,
and we have a hotcake-and-sausage combo.
And, of course, comes with syrup
and butter.
Very natural pose.
Very natural feeling right now.
♪ Always up for a pour, yes! ♪
Breakfast is served.
Oatmeal.
On the side, to be mixed in,
cranberries and raisins
and
diced --
oh!
Diced apples.
[slurps]
And here we've got Mega Muffin.
Pork patties.
That's huge one.
Mini pancakes.
Oh, cute.
It comes with apple cream sauce.
Ooh.
Ooh, this is perfect for breakfast.
I would get it.
Bacon egg McSandwich.
So, it's got bacon
and round egg
and cheddar cheese.
That's it.
And you might be surprised,
we've got Filet-O-Fish.
Ta-da!
So, Filet-O-Fish is on the breakfast menu.
I guess Japanese people tend to
eat fish for breakfast.
Three exclusive burgers here in the US
are variations on the
Quarter Pounder with cheese.
Yes, we've all seen "Pulp Fiction,"
we know about the whole
Quarter Pounder thing.
Does not exist outside of the US,
I don't think.
So, probably why they don't have
Quarter Pounders in Japan.
The classic Quarter Pounder with cheese.
Look at this guy.
I mean, this was maybe my
go-to one for a decade.
The Quarter Pounder with cheese deluxe.
I don't know.
I feel like this is
pretty close to a Whopper.
I'm not a big Whopper guy,
but there you go,
a deluxe Quarter Pounder with cheese.
The double Quarter Pounder with cheese.
Look at the size of this thing!
Yes, sir.
Japan's exclusive burgers.
Teriyaki McBurger,
which is my most favorite one.
My body is made of McTeriyaki burger.
[angelic singing]
So, it's got mayo right there,
and lettuce, pork patties,
dip it into delicious teriyaki sauce,
and it's covering whole
pork patties perfectly.
Joe, when you come to
Japan, please try this.
You will thank me later.
Everything that they have
looks so good and sounds so good.
Man, when I go to Tokyo,
first stop, I'm going to McDonald's.
Sushi, ramen, get it out of my face.
I want the teriyaki burger.
That's the first thing I'm
getting when I get there.
Mm!
I'm getting full, actually.
[laughs]
Slow down, George. We got
a lot of food to cover.
[dance music]
All right, so we've got
bacon lettuce burger right here.
It looks sad.
Egg cheeseburger,
but we also call it Eguchi.
Eguchi is an abbreviation
for egg cheeseburger.
Japanese people love abbreviation.
It's got ketchup and pickle, round egg,
and cheddar cheese and beef patties.
Next one.
Spicy beef burger.
Ooh, look at this!
Oh, it looks so spicy!
It has spicy mayo or something like that.
So, here we've got Samurai Mac.
Samurai!
Samurai Mac?
Yo, that sounds awesome.
And this blue one
is called roasted soy
sauce double thick beef.
We've got roasted soy sauce
bacon tomato thick beef.
So if you want a little bit more, like,
healthy veggies,
go for it.
Uh, yeah, George, I don't know if that
makes that much healthier there
'cause it also has twice
as much meat and cheese.
If you're looking to be healthy
at a McDonald's in Japan,
I'd stick with the vegetable juice.
And this one right here is called
Teriyaki chicken Filet-O.
Wow. So much sauce.
So, next one, we've got ebi Filet-O.
Ebi means shrimp,
so it's a shrimp Filet-O.
Oh, yeah. It's got aurora sauce.
Aurora sauce is like
ketchup and mayonnaise.
So, it's got a lot of shrimp in there.
Mm!
So good. So good.
In the US, we have about
four exclusive chicken
sandwiches specifically.
I didn't see this on the menu,
but apparently you guys
don't have a McChicken,
which is just chicken sandwich.
Regular bun, mayo,
chicken.
Yeah.
We also have,
check this out, spicy McChicken.
So pretty much the same McChicken,
but they put spicy coating
on the breading on the chicken.
Every fast-food chain in America right now
is having what we're calling
the fried-chicken-sandwich wars.
Popeyes, Burger King,
of course McDonald's,
all of them are at this arms race
to have the best chicken sandwich.
I think 'cause Chick-fil-A
has edged everyone out.
These are the three that
are currently available.
I don't know for how long.
You have the crispy chicken sandwich.
I think it's a brioche bun,
pickles, and no sauce,
which I think is strange.
So, like, the whole flavor
is just the chicken.
Spicy chicken sandwich.
Same deal,
but, of course, spicy sauce.
And the spicy chicken deluxe,
which, to George's point,
has more vegetables on it.
You know, to be healthier.
OK, so when it comes to side menus,
we've got Shaka Shaka Chicken,
and we have
two fla --
[thunder rumbles]
oh!
Two flavors.
Can you hear that?
Thunder, thunder, thunder!
'Cause it's rainy season in Japan.
It's the sunny season here
in Southern California.
And here is red pepper.
And this one is cheddar cheese.
[thundering]
Thunder, stop!
So, all you have to do is just
put the powder into the bag
and shake it.
[paper rattling]
And the powder should be covering
the whole Shaka Chicken.
[thundering]
Ooh, big one!
Like this.
This I've seen before. This I want.
That's the thing I want the
most at a Japanese McDonald's.
US McDonald's, we have the bags,
we have the chicken.
Just get the spice packets. Throw it in.
George: We've got side salad,
and it comes with this
roasted sesame dressing.
Let's go!
Ooh.
That was cool.
Now put it all in the garbage.
We've got edamame and corn.
Yogurt,
and there's cow,
cow.
Exclusive sauces.
It's sauce talk time.
Sauce Talk.
We have sweet 'n sour sauce.
They gave me
hot mustard.
This was supposed to be honey mustard.
You guys have hot mustard?
I know you don't have honey mustard.
Of course, ranch.
Ooh, spicy Buffalo.
Now, these might be promotions
'cause of that singing group BTS,
but we have right now a
Cajun sauce and a sweet chili sauce.
This sauce is fantastic.
This is the sauce. This
has to stay on the menu.
So, these two are new ones.
This one right here is
soy sauce, best sauce.
Man. This is fantastic!
Good job!
Very good taste.
So, this one right here is called
Louisiana hot sauce.
Ooh, it does look like very spicy one.
This is not spicy at all.
Actually, we were supposed
to have bai burger options,
but unfortunately you can
only get them from 5:30 p.m.
But let me explain what bai burger is.
Bai simply means double in Japanese.
So if you order a normal Big Mac,
it has two beef patties, right?
But if you order bai Big Mac,
it has four beef patties.
But not only Big Mac, but all burgers
adopts the bai burger options.
That's funny.
You can only get double
the meat after 5:30,
that's really funny.
That would not stand
in this country at all.
People would lose their minds.
Four patties?
On a Big Mac?
So after shooting this video,
I'm going to order bai Big Mac.
And then bye-bye, health.
You ain't gotta tell me, George!
Bye, health!
All right, here are all the ingredients
for a US Big Mac.
Oh, God.
The bun. It has:
enriched flour, which is wheat flour,
[fast-forwarding]
vinegar, and contains wheat.
On to the beef patty.
100% pure USDA inspected beef,
no fillers, no extenders!
Prepared on the grill with seasoning,
salt and black pepper.
There you go. There you go.
Try the lettuce ingredients,
lettuce.
Nice.
The Big Mac sauce ingredients.
Soybean oil,
[fast-forwarding]
extractives of paprika, soy lecithin.
[burps]
The pickle slice ingredients.
Cucumbers, water, distilled vinegar,
salt, calcium chloride, alum,
potassium sorbate as a preservative,
natural flavors, polysorbate 80,
extractives of turmeric for color.
Onion ingredients.
Onions.
There you go.
A few things I want to note.
Alum is used to dissolve steel.
Polysorbate 80 has been linked
to colon cancer in mice.
Cue the dancing mice.
[dance music]
And caramel color is on
California's list of chemicals
that may cause cancer and
reproductive toxicity,
good God.
Counterpoint.
They all taste fantastic.
So, McDonald's Japan doesn't disclose
their ingredients in the Big Mac.
However, they do tell us where
the ingredients come from.
If you order a Big Mac in Japan,
you'll eat beef from
Australia or New Zealand;
buns made from wheat
imported from the USA,
Canada, and Australia;
and pickles made from
cucumbers grown in Turkey,
Sri Lanka, or India;
onions grown in the USA or India;
sliced cheddar cheese made in New Zealand,
Australia, the USA, or Japan;
and lettuce grown in Japan,
Taiwan, the USA, or Malaysia.
The only ingredients that come from Japan
are the cheese and the lettuce.
And even then, McDonald's
still imports some lettuce
and cheese from other countries.
So this is a very international burger.
Thank you, world!
In Japan, our Big Mac is 525 calories
and 28.3 grams of fat
and 1,007 milligrams of sodium
and 41.8 grams of carbs
and 26 grams of protein.
In the US, our Big Mac is 550 calories,
30 grams of fat,
1,010 milligrams of sodium,
45 grams of carbs,
and 25 grams of protein.
So the US has a slight increase
on everything except protein.
So, in Japan, our five-piece nuggets
is 270 calories
and 17.2 grams of fat
and 506 milligrams of sodium
and 13.1 grams of carbs
and 15.8 grams of protein.
Broken down, each nugget is 54 calories.
We don't have a five-piece here in the US,
but we do have this, a 10-piece.
Let's get those stats on the screen.
Go ahead and divide everything by two,
and, yes, now we have the
stats for a five-piece.
Pretty smart, eh?
If we want to divide all
that by, I think, five,
you'll get the stats for one nugget.
[sighs] This is so exhausting.
In Japan, if you order a Big Mac meal
with large fries and a
medium chocolate shake,
the grand total will be 1,405 calories.
And in the US, adding medium fries
and a medium chocolate shake to a Big Mac,
the grand total is 1,660 calories.
And that is a calorie increase of 18.14%.
If you're wondering why
we're using a large fry
but a medium chocolate shake,
it turns out that in Japan,
you can't get a large chocolate shake.
They'll only sell it to you in medium.
I'm assuming because they don't want you
eating that much ice cream.
Tianran: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find all the differences
between McDonald's in the US and China.
This is "Food Wars."
New season, USA versus China.
I'm so excited for you guys to see this
and to meet our new cohost, Tianran.
USA versus China, let's go.
Drinks from McDonald's in
China come in three sizes,
small, medium, and big.
But for some reason the
medium is 444 milliliters,
which in Chinese basically
just means die, die, die,
which is just super unlucky,
so I guess they really
want you to either get
the large or the small.
The drinks at a US
McDonald's come four sizes,
the extra small, where'd it go?
Sorry, they forgot it.
The small, the medium, and the large.
Our large is 80.9% bigger
than China's largest soda.
Let's see if that's true.
Bound to be a little bit in the lid.
That is blasphemous!
Shame these people. Shame this clown.
Some of you over the past several years
have said something to the tune of,
it doesn't count or it's wrong
because we add the ice, or
we keep the ice in there,
and that isn't a true measurement,
which I don't believe, but fine.
For the first time ever,
I want to measure this without the ice.
I'm solving this once and for all.
So, right away you get even less soda.
Let's get this up to
exactly 32 fluid ounces.
32 ounces of Coca-Cola
in the supposed 32-ounce McDonald's cup.
I'm so sick of this.
Why are they saying 32 fluid ounces?
Look! Just say 30 or 31. It's fine.
Your move, McDonald's.
Our fries come in three sizes:
small, medium, and large.
American fries come in three sizes:
We will now weigh our largest fry.
So, what about McNuggets?
Here in China, you can only get them
as an order of five or 10,
which is really just two portions of five.
That's cute, China. Real cute.
Here in the US, we have way
many more nugget options.
Four-piece, for your infant,
six-piece, 10-piece, 20-piece,
and our largest, the 40-piece.
All the mathheads watching
will be quick to point out
that this is 300% of
China's largest portion.
So, here are all the McDonald's
menu items from China
that you won't find in the US.
Here are all the
McDonald's items in the US
you won't find in China.
Oh, my God, I've been
staring at this for so long.
This is incredible. Check out the back!
It's an origami apple! This is the best.
Let's see what we got.
A hamburger, mini fries,
a drink, a corn cup.
[gasps] Dun-dun-dun!
Po!
Oh, my God, this is way
better than the Hamburglar.
What? do I have to build Po as well?
This is -- [laughs] I'm too old for this.
Anyway, if you don't want a hamburger,
you can also change this
out for a fish fillet
or for four pieces of nuggets.
You can also get the corn cup
changed out for apple slices,
but they will cost you 1 kuai extra.
And with the juice, you can
have either apple juice,
milk, or water.
So only healthy options
here in China's McDonald's.
OK, now on to the toy.
So, this is going to take
a while. Give me a second.
Ugh.
And then something flips
out from behind his groin.
In here! It's coming together!
Oh!
It's a basketball hoop.
Oh, my God, this is ingenuity at its best.
Look, we can play hoops with this.
Three, two, one!
Whoa!
I noticed that his Happy
Meal, even the box was a toy.
In America, our Happy Meal box
is another opportunity
for an advertisement.
All-new season of "The Masked
Singer" on Fox. Check it out.
Jesus, they're shameless. These kids.
Remember before, the
extra-small fry? Found it.
More nuggets, a four-piece.
Apple slices.
Our toy is decidedly not a puzzle.
Remember when Kermit
the Frog was in there?
That was weird.
OK, what is this?
Who? What celebrity was the fox?
Oh, it was Wayne Brady.
OK, I've heard of him.
What, is his head in here?
Oddly enough, shows the stark difference
between China and the US.
Theirs has this puzzle to put together,
ours is an ad for a TV show.
[laughs and cries]
OK, so these are our
exclusive beef burgers.
Here in China, people mostly eat pork,
so I think with the beef
they've really had to
go the premium route,
so you've got some
interesting combinations.
This is the German sausage
double beef burger,
but in Chinese the name is kind of like
the "anti-vegetarian tyrant."
So they've got some pretty
aggressive marketing for this.
Imagine Terry Crews just
pulsing his pecks while he --
what is that?
Ugh.
If this is what they
call a German sausage,
then I think the Germans
will be very angry.
Here we've got a BLT double beef burger.
I'm so sad. What is this?
This is like a BLT sandwich
that's been sat at the bottom
of your bag for a week.
I'm excited about these, though.
These are the Angus
max thick beef burgers.
Now, McDonald's have done
premium collaborations
with Michelin-starred chefs in the past,
and they even have these
really super-fancy packaging.
Look at that. Double cheeseburger.
Oh, wow! Look at that.
The meat patty is thicker than my thumb.
That's a proper burger.
Mm.
Well, it's very meaty. Incredibly cheesy.
This is the double cheeseburger,
so I can understand that.
For the vast majority of Chinese people,
their understanding or
access to Western food
may really come from
fast-food restaurants.
So this is probably the
gourmet burger experience
for the vast majority of
the Chinese population.
In the US, you can get a
Quarter Pounder with cheese.
What the heck? They gave us two tops?
This is the special two-top
Quarter Pounder with cheese, apparently.
And we also have a double Quarter Pounder,
if you want to increase the meat.
If someone wants to get
their daily vegetables,
here is the Quarter
Pounder with cheese deluxe.
Swimming in mayonnaise.
We have something in the United
States called the McDouble.
If you want slightly less
cheese on a double cheeseburger,
we got you covered.
Quarter Pounder with bacon.
Every once in a while, they
just take a Quarter Pounder
and put bacon on it,
and they repackage it for a celebrity.
And these are our exclusive
chicken and fish options.
So, I want to start you off with this,
which has since become
McDonald's best spicy burger.
This is the McSpicy chicken fillet.
Apparently it's 1,000 SHU,
which is a Scoville unit,
and it's roughly equivalent
to the spiciness you get
from a spicy and numbing hot pot,
and those guys are pretty spicy.
Mm. Oh, that's delicious.
You don't feel the burn at first,
and then it's like your tongue
slowly starts to wake up,
and it's like a frog in a pot.
It slowly starts to realize
it's being boiled alive,
and by the end of this burger,
you're going to want that Coke.
Now, this is McDonald's
best-selling non-spicy burger,
the grilled chicken sandwich,
which supposedly has no growth hormones
in their chicken feed.
Very heavy on the black
pepper. Oh. Ooh, wow.
I'm very excited about this.
This is the McCrunch
chicken fillet burger,
and in Chinese the name is "katsusui."
It sounds like how it's supposed to taste.
"Ka" is kind of like "crunchy,"
and "tsu" is kind of like
the juice kind of squirting out.
So this should be both crunchy and juicy.
Ooh, that looks like a much
better piece of chicken.
Yes, yes.
I didn't get the "ka,"
probably because this has gone a bit cold,
but look at that. It is juicy in there.
OK, this is the
super-spicy chicken fillet.
Look at this guy!
You know this is going to
be super spicy. It's orange!
It's not that spicy.
[coughs] Ooh!
It's not as -- oh!
Oh, my God.
Very tasty.
Finish that, and it's
to the hospital you go. Whew.
And last but, in my opinion,
least, the double fish burger.
Chicken sandwiches.
There's something that is new-ish,
the bacon ranch McCrispy.
Hm.
It's just OK.
There's also a bacon
ranch deluxe McCrispy,
where deluxe equals more vegetables.
The McCrispy is something that
we ordered and they forgot.
And then now, piling on the vegetables,
you got the McCrispy deluxe.
Spicy McCrispy.
So they just rebranded the
crispy chicken sandwich
to be the McCrispy?
How spicy can this be?
This is not spicy at all.
So, McDonald's China has one roll option,
which is this crispy pork and
pickled bamboo shoot wrap.
Mm.
That's tasty. It's nice and crunchy.
Very spicy! [laughs] Wow.
Mm.
It's spicy. It's sour.
Anything that has Sichuan peppercorn in it
is just incredible.
Here we've got the McSpicy wings,
which come in portions of two, four,
or nine.
Straight up, I wish we had those wings.
Those wings look really good.
Also, I don't know if you've noticed,
but the decoration here on the packet,
this is a collaboration
with a streetwear brand
called Clot, or C-L-O-T,
and it uses traditional
Chinese aesthetics.
So here you've got the lucky knot,
which is sort of like a symbol
for good luck and longevity.
As Chinese as it gets.
And this is also the same
flavor as the McSpicy burger.
I don't know if there's an
accurate translation for this.
This is literally called
"such a big chicken chop."
It's about the same size as
my palm, a little bit bigger.
The McCrispy chicken.
Mm. Crispy, wow.
Mm, yes!
This is very special.
We didn't think we'd be
able to get this today.
This is the
spicy lobster-flavored chicken tenders.
The Chinese says "yao yao,"
which means you have to shake it.
Oh, let's try these babies.
There was no need to shake it at all.
There's no seasoning there at all.
It's just literally chicken tenders.
It's more of an aspiration
towards lobster, though.
And we've got crinkle-cut fries.
Oh, how I've missed you.
Mm. Nothing beats a crinkle-cut fry.
In China, we have a bunch
of different barrel options.
For example, this one is
the Golden Arches bucket,
which actually didn't come in a bucket,
they just put everything into a box.
The name actually is the
reason why we got this,
because McDonald's in China
has officially renamed to Jingongmen,
which literally translates
as Golden Arches,
and when they did that
they caught a lot of flak.
Everybody started laughing at them.
Nobody calls them the
Golden Arches in Chinese.
It's just McDonald's.
But legally they are now
known as the Golden Arches.
Featuring sauces, you know
what that means, Yuelei.
Sauce talk.
Here are all of our exclusive sauces.
Garlic chili.
That's pretty much it.
Oh, and no Sichuan sauce, either.
That's an American invention,
just like General Tso's chicken.
But here in China, you
don't really get sauces
unless you ask for them.
They come with the nuggets.
Chinese people expect food to be complete
when it arrives at your table.
You don't go and add more sauce to it.
Sauces. In the United
States, optimal for dipping.
Tangy barbecue. Spicy Buffalo.
It's the USA, so you
know we got that ranch.
Honey mustard.
Honey, which is not here.
I don't know where it is.
Mayonnaise, which also
they did not include.
Mexican-style salsa.
These are our exclusive desserts.
I am going to try every
single one of them.
We can start with the taro pie.
Taro is kind of like a cross
between sweet potato and potato.
It's often used in desserts in Asia.
You'll find them in everything
from pies to bubble tea.
It's a bit like yam with a bit of jam,
but it's subtly sweet.
For Chinese people, if you say
a dessert is not very sweet,
that's actually a compliment.
Pineapple pie, also one of my favorites.
Mm. That is heavenly.
I think I'm going to finish this.
Now I need to chew for a very long time.
So, here we've got the strawberry sundae,
which is kind of melted already,
but I'm sure it would've been
amazing when it first arrived.
An affogato and a
matcha-flavored affogato,
and then here we've got the McFlurrys.
This is the strawberry McFlurry
with Oreo cookies.
Oh, my gosh, that is perhaps
the most sinful thing
that you could have.
Oh, but it's so good.
This is just the regular McFlurry,
and here is my all-time favorite,
mango-pomelo-sago-flavored McFlurry.
Hm. It's very different
with the ice cream.
You still got the mango in there,
and the pomelo, it's
very juicy, it's tender,
like little tiny pips in there
that kind of pop when you eat them.
Oh! Just perfect.
Mm. Brain freeze. Oh!
In the US, you can get yourself
a McFlurry with mini M&M's.
For some reason, mini M&M's
taste better than regular M&M's.
I love mini M&M's. Mm.
Hot caramel sundae.
It's classic. They don't
have this in China?
God, I mean, what's more
American than an apple pie?
Look at this thing. Let's
crack that bad boy open.
We got chocolate chip cookies.
Shakes. You can get three
different types of shakes
here at a US McDonald's. Chocolate.
Classic chocolate.
Strawberry, personal favorite.
That's so good.
Vanilla, the classic.
Our exclusive drinks
include the Fuze iced tea.
We've got the Minute Maid orange McFloat,
bubble tea, soy milk,
pure milk, Ceylon black tea,
which in China we would call red tea,
which just confuses you for fun.
I'm going to go back to here
because this is the
only thing I want to try
out of all of them.
That tastes like orange juice.
It's just plain old orange juice.
In the US, you can get
yourself a Dr Pepper,
a Fanta orange and an
Orange Lavaburst, lemonade.
You can also get frozen drinks.
You can get a frozen Fanta
blue raspberry or frozen Coke.
McDonald's also has smoothies.
A mango pineapple smoothie
and a strawberry smoothie.
Yeah, they make a decent
smoothie at McDonald's.
As you can see,
we have an absolute ton of
breakfast options here in China.
I think McDonald's has done
fantastic in this regard
because the Chinese treat
breakfast as a very special meal.
We have a very similar saying to,
"Eat breakfast like a king,
lunch like a prince,
dinner like a pauper."
So, starting with the
sausage McMuffin with egg.
Always a good way to start the day.
You can get this as a double as well.
Next we have the ham muffin.
It's just literally a piece of ham,
some lettuce, and two muffins,
so I guess this would
actually be a hamburger.
You can get this as a double as well.
Next we have the grilled chicken muffin.
This chicken's been
sitting around for a while.
Next we've got the
crispy chicken McMuffin.
So this is the breakfast version of the
"such a big chicken chop."
Breakfast in the US. We have
so many breakfast options,
starting down here, the sandwiches.
Egg McMuffin. Maybe the first
fast breakfast sandwich
to ever hit the market.
Sausage McMuffin. Sausage and cheese.
If you hadn't noticed,
this is all on what we
call an English muffin,
'cause they're from England.
There's also a bacon,
egg, and cheese McMuffin.
But the option that we have most for
are the scrambled-egg burgers.
Scrambled-egg grilled chicken burger.
The scrambled egg is
very luminously yellow.
Wow, look at that.
Very peppery.
They love their pepper here, don't they?
So, the scrambled-egg sausage burger.
You'll notice the buns are different now.
We're no longer on the muffins.
We're back to regular buns.
Oh, it's squeezing out, isn't it?
Scrambled-egg cheeseburger.
This is the brightest burger
I've ever seen in my life.
It's definitely very portable.
I think that's one thing that
McDonald's has done very well,
because Chinese breakfast
traditionally is not too portable
in the sense that you need to
sit down to a lot of meals,
like if you want to eat
wonton in the morning
or if you want to eat
some soups in the morning.
This you can just take and go.
And, of course, you can
get the scrambled-egg
German-flavor-sausage burger.
Oh, at least they give you two,
as opposed to just one tiny sausage.
Biscuits, biscuits, biscuits.
Sausage and egg biscuit.
So, the biscuits are the
same breakfast sandwiches
you get in English-muffin form,
but in this biscuit form,
the American biscuit,
this dry, crumbly, buttery biscuit,
there is a bacon, egg, and cheese one.
For some reason people in this country
seem to want just a biscuit and sausage
with no sauce, no nothing.
This is as dry as if
you'd go into a barbershop
and take a handful of hair clippings
and just shove them in your
mouth. This is that dry.
In the US we have something
called McGriddles,
and McGriddles are breakfast sandwiches
where they replace the
English muffin and/or biscuit
with pancakes.
So, first of all, they got the
McDonald's logo right there.
Too hilarious.
Somehow, through the miracle of science,
was able to inject syrup
into these pancakes.
Sensational.
You can get your McGriddles
in sausage, egg, and cheese
and then just sausage.
On to what I was going to
talk about, the congee.
Congee is a very traditional
breakfast item here in China.
It's basically just rice porridge,
and it's something that is
kind of like chicken
soup for Chinese people,
in the sense that if you fall ill,
you're going to be given one
of these, plain, with nothing.
This I think is with century egg,
but the century egg,
it tastes a little bit
like a blue-cheese version of egg,
in that it's kind of
like egg that's gone off,
but in a very nice way.
And this adds a nice
savoriness to the congee.
You can also get it with
pickles and bamboo shoots.
And if you're going to get congee,
then usually you need to pair it
with what they've called
an "Asian dough stick."
This is what we call a youtiao,
which is literally a stick of fried dough.
These are absolutely amazing
when paired with stuff like soy milk
and, of course, with congee.
You know, you need to eat these fresh.
Deep-fried, they are so incredibly crispy.
Oh, wow, well done, McDonald's.
Like, 10 hours later,
these are still crispy.
I'm very impressed but
also a little bit worried
because they should never be
this crispy after that long.
I wonder what they've put in here.
Last but not least, our
German sausages again.
It's not just sandwiches, you guys.
We also have something in the US,
the Big Breakfast, which
is totally in disarray.
This is like the advertising
for this breakfast.
I'm sorry?
The Big Breakfast with pancakes.
You can also get hotcakes, aka pancakes.
There's no way they're back
there, like, ladling the ...
right? There's no way they're doing that.
These have to be premade and
they just heat them up, right?
So, hotcakes and sausage.
Oh, and they both come with syrup,
so you know what we gotta do.
Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho, yeah!
We also have a
morning wrap with ham.
The wrap itself is basically frozen solid.
We can exchange that with sausage,
which is also frozen.
It's almost like a piece of art now,
like you're supposed to look
at it instead of eating it.
Wow, frozen in time.
US McDonald's have
sausage breakfast burritos.
I mean, I can't even unfold,
I'm just, like, ripping it apart.
You got scrambled eggs, the sausage,
it comes with Mexican-style salsa.
Hey, McDonald's, it's actually pretty good
considering that this is, like,
probably the furthest
you can get from salsa
and still legally be
able to call it salsa.
If you're not trying to
completely destroy your insides
first thing in the morning,
you can get yourself
fruit and maple oatmeal.
Seems like your breakfast
is trying to escape
your body an hour later,
might actually be able to hold this down.
Et voilà, ze options from le bakery.
So, we have macarons.
Right now we have two different flavors,
chocolate and berries.
These actually look really legit.
Pat yourself on the back.
This is really good.
And these things are lamingtons.
I've never actually had lamingtons.
Apparently, they're basically
Australian sponge cakes
which are covered in coconut flakes,
and this is a lemon-flavored one.
Surprisingly addictive.
We have the McCafé bakery.
At the McCafé bakery, you
get, you know, sweet treats,
not necessarily for breakfast
but probably leaning more
towards breakfast time.
Ba-bam, blueberry muffin.
A cinnamon roll with
cream cheese frosting.
It looks like it's squishy.
It most certainly is not.
I mean, come on, who doesn't
love an apple fritter?
An apple fritter is a doughnut
that tastes like apple
and is shaped like it was
just squoze in someone's hand
for some strange reason.
These are our McCafé drink options,
starting with the extra-milky
latte with oat milk.
A latte is two-thirds milk,
and then you add oat milk in there,
I don't think we're going
to have much coffee.
Oh. Oh, wow, that is surprisingly good.
In China, oat milk has
really, really taken off
because a lot of people did
not grow up drinking milk.
A lot of Chinese people
are lactose intolerant.
And so oat milk is definitely
a very healthy alternative,
and that's why we have the
extra-strong chocolate with oat milk.
You can also get this without oat milk.
Extra-strong matcha milk.
Extra-strong matcha --
oh, we have so much matcha.
Extra-strong chocolate smoothie,
extra-strong milk and vanilla smoothie,
and the matcha milk with matcha jelly.
Matcha, matcha, oh, I'm going to --
We absolutely love matcha here
in China. I don't know why.
It tastes like grass and frozen grass.
Coffees and coffees and
coffees and coffees.
McDonald's has a assortment
of featured drinks,
espresso drinks, mochas, iced lattes.
Let's get all that on the screen.
See? All these things.
This is the cold brew. This is so strong.
I think each of you should
eventually take a sip.
You will not believe how
strong the cold brew is.
Oh, my God.
French vanilla latte.
This is the exact
opposite. This is so sweet.
Mocha. Who doesn't want hot chocolate
first thing in the morning?
Hilarious, people are buying that.
Ooh, this is the premium roast coffee.
I know I've been kind of dissing on it,
but their actual coffee, the
actual McDonald's coffee,
I think is very good.
They're a good contender in
the coffee game, I think,
in the fast-food coffee game.
Especially the horrible
PR nightmare they had
when they, like, destroyed
that lady's crotch
with their superhot coffee.
It is a comeback story, McDonald's.
Almost killing a woman
with second-degree burns
from boiling-hot coffee
to these nice little fun café drinks.
I would happily pour
this all over my crotch.
You can get the iced-coffee drinks.
Don't like this. This is the mocha.
McDonald's in China also
has a late-night menu.
They only have one item,
but this is worth it.
I got it last night. These
are marinated chicken bones.
They don't sound very appealing,
but the Chinese name
is wordplay on an idiom
which kind of means "the
highest level of artistry."
And when I opened up this box,
[gasps]
I literally heard angels going, "Aah!"
This is actually a street food
from someplace up in Northeast
China called Shenyang.
Chinese people love fiddly stuff,
and meat on the bone is
just that much more tasty.
Ah, still incredible, even cold.
You know, the box actually
says "marinated chicken bones."
"Be careful, it may contain bones."
And you're actually supposed
to spit the bones out,
but I'm having so much
fun eating this thing,
I actually eat the bones too.
It's spicy, it's sour, it's sweet.
Ah, and just absolutely divine.
I can see how people would be
inspired after eating this.
So, McDonald's came to China in 1990,
and then it opened in Beijing in '92.
Back then, that was the largest
McDonald's in the world.
They had 700 seats.
On opening day, they served 40,000 people.
And people didn't go there for the food.
It was a place to be seen.
Like, McDonald's was a window to the West.
It was a cosmopolitan place
to experience capitalism, in a way.
But over time it became
a trendy hangout spot
for city kids after school.
They'd go there to do their homework.
It still very much is middle class.
I remember actually when I came
to visit China 20 years ago,
my aunts greeted me at the
airport with bags of McDonald's,
and I was actually kind of offended
that they would bring junk food to meet me
as opposed to real Chinese food,
but for them McDonald's
was the best of the best.
It was all the prestige.
Hey, to me, McDonald's,
when it comes to fast food,
is No. 1 in the US, dare I say the world.
If you just want a good hot meal
where you know exactly what
it's going to taste like
and get it and go, McDonald's never fails.
Waiting in line, getting
it at the drive-through,
you get it lickety-split.
Now they leaned really big
into delivery since COVID,
and, man, McDonald's is
showing up right away,
and I love it. It's dangerous.
I can't remember the last time
I've eaten inside at a McDonald's.
So, I usually dine in at McDonald's,
but I find that in China
they focus more on delivery,
and they promise to get
everything delivered
within 30 minutes, which
they actually keep to,
and that's incredibly impressive.
Last night I ordered the chicken carcass.
It took 28 minutes.
Got a Big Mac earlier.
That was 10 minutes.
So they're very, very punctual.
They're also open for very long,
from 7 till 10 p.m.,
and there are many 24-hour branches,
so extremely convenient.
Now, McDonald's is an American brand,
so they have American
classics on the menu,
hamburgers, chicken sandwiches,
but they kind of
assimilated and made popular
the burger culture in this country.
It's hard to say, because I feel like
the American taste is McDonald's.
I think McDonald's has actually adapted
pretty well to Chinese tastes.
Besides the McSpicy burger and wings
and the grilled chicken sandwich,
which have all become bestsellers,
McDonald's actually
uses chicken thigh meat
instead of breast meat in
all of its chicken burgers,
except for the McChicken.
And I think that's because Chinese people
think chicken breast is dry,
and they've also got lots
of time-limited specials
when it comes to the desserts,
like the mantou burger,
which is kind of like a Chinese bun,
and even cilantro sundae.
McDonald's, everyone's
going after McDonald's.
Burger King's been going after McDonald's
since, what, the '60s?
Every burger chain
try to get some sort
of edge on McDonald's.
We're fancier, we got
different varieties of stuff.
McDonald's is No. 1,
here, now, and forever.
The McDonald's logo should be
on the American flag, dammit!
So, China is McDonald's
second-largest market
by store count, after the US.
In China, there are over
5,000 McDonald's locations,
but KFC has over 9,000.
They actually came here first,
so it's KFC, then McDonald's,
then a local brand called Dicos,
which does both fried chicken and burgers,
so they're really just
fighting an uphill battle.
In China, a Big Mac costs 25 yuan.
A Big Mac in the US costs $5.29.
Make it a Big Mac meal
with a medium fries and
medium Coke, and it's 36 yuan.
If you want to go large,
that's 4 yuan extra
for a grand total of 40 yuan.
If you make it a meal
with a medium fries and medium drink,
price goes up to $9.29.
Upgrade that to a large, and it's $10.79.
Our Big Mac large meal costs 86% more.
So our Big Mac meal is cheaper,
but at the same time
the average daily wage
of a cabby in Beijing is
about 200 yuan, give or take,
and so this would be 20% of their salary.
So it's still not really something
that you would eat on a regular
basis, but maybe splurge on.
Let's talk nutrition.
This is that very Big Mac, again.
In the US, it's 590 calories
and all this stuff.
In China, our Big Mac has 524 calories,
26 grams of fat, 45 grams of carbs,
27 grams of protein,
and 877 milligrams of sodium.
What if we did a combo?
Starting with the medium fries,
this adds 320 calories to the meal,
and all this stuff.
While a medium fries in
China contains 290 calories,
13 grams of total fat,
35.9 grams of carbs,
we're not sure if it contains any sugars,
4 grams of protein,
and 252 milligrams of sodium.
But you need something to drink.
Add in a medium Coke to that,
and this kicks your meal
up another 210 calories.
We'll do the same.
Here's everything in a
medium Coke in China.
148 calories. That leaves the grand total
for the China meal at 962 calories.
While in the US, the total
ends up looking like this.
1,120 calories and all this other stuff.
Get a load of that sodium, though.
Guh!
Claudia: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between McDonald's in the US and Italy.
This is "Food Wars."
Drinks at McDonald's in
Italy come in three sizes,
250 milliliters,
400 milliliters,
and 500 milliliters.
We're now going to measure
a 500-ml Coke to see if that's true.
Oh, oh.
I think we're surpassing that.
It's just right below the 600 mark,
but almost there.
So quite generous.
Drinks in the US also come in four sizes.
The extra small, which is 355 milliliters,
or 12 fluid ounces.
The small, 474 milliliters,
or 16 fluid ounces.
And the medium, 621
milliliters, or 21 fluid ounces.
And the large, 946 milliliters,
or 32 fluid ounces.
Since we were the ones that
filled this up at the restaurant
and I don't think we got it all full up,
I'm going to go ahead and fill this
what I think is reasonable.
I can't do to the top
because the cap is recessed.
OK. 32? Surely you jest.
But there's the 32 line. Not even close.
It's closer to 24 than it is 32.
So, fries in Italy come in three sizes.
The regular, which is
technically the small,
medium, and large.
Here in America, our
fries come in four sizes.
The kids, which comes in the Happy Meal.
Look at this little guy.
Little guy!
The small, the medium, and the large.
All the "Food Wars" heads watching
know that in the China episode,
our large McDonald's fry was 175 grams.
In the Japan episode,
our large McDonald's fry was 190 grams.
So clearly there's some
difference in grammage
depending on, I don't know,
the McDonald's we go to,
the scooper, who knows?
So we're going to weigh
our large right now.
Ready? Fantastic.
Eh, let's go 185.
Not a bad scoop. We got
a good scooper this time.
Seems pretty small, actually.
What about McNuggets?
In Italy you can get a bag of four,
a box of six pieces,
nine pieces, and 20 pieces.
Claudia, in the US,
our McNuggets are
available in these sizes:
the four-piece, the
six-piece, 10-piece, 20-piece,
which you also have, but we go
up one more here in America.
Our largest size, the 40-piece.
Now, if my calculations are correct,
this is double your largest size.
The iconic Big Mac.
Both countries have it,
but we're going to compare
ours to Italy's by weighing it.
226 grams for a US Big Mac.
And here is an Italian Big Mac,
or Il Big Mac, as is written here,
and we're going to weigh it now.
209 grams.
Here are all the items on
the McDonald's Italy menu
that you won't find in the US.
And here are all the McDonald's
menu items from the US
you won't find in Italy.
Get a good look, Claudia.
Let's start from the burgers.
We have a bunch of Italian burgers
that you won't get in the US.
The first one we got here
is a chicken Big Mac.
Oh, right. Just destroyed chicken Big Mac.
Has that been inverted?
Is that supposed to look like this?
The cheese helps a little
bit. Sauce as well.
Moving on, we have a bacon Big Mac.
Yeah, there's two strips of bacon,
but they're not quite
big, so it does look like
maybe it's just one
that's been cut in half.
We got a crispy McBacon,
which is like cheeseburger,
double patty, and some bacon
again, a bit on the side.
It's funny actually because growing up,
I thought that the crispy McBacon
was the iconic McDonald's item,
and it's weird that it is
actually an Italian exclusive.
Here are all the burgers in the US
that you can't get in Italy.
Starting down here, the
Quarter Pounder with cheese.
It really is just a cheeseburger
that is a quarter pound of meat.
It's a great go-to burger.
Meat, cheese, onions,
pickles, ketchup, and mustard.
And if you want more meat,
you can get the double Quarter Pounder.
Correct. Not the half pounder,
the double Quarter Pounder with cheese.
Two patties, more meat, more cheese.
Fantastic sandwich.
And then we've got the first one
of the My Selection range,
which is a range that was
designed with Joe Bastianich.
He's an American TV personality and chef.
This one is speck and Asiago,
so yeah, very traditional.
Speck is a type of cured
meat. It's like a smoked ham.
Yeah, it's a smoked ham
from the north of Italy.
It's actually very, very nice,
just very salty with that smoky flavor.
It's one of my favorites.
And then we have Asiago,
which is a cheese made
pretty much in the same area.
There's also mayo and zucchini in there.
A bit dry, I think.
You do taste the cold cut, the speck.
Just brings that saltiness, smokiness.
Very nice, and the cheese
also is quite good.
Yeah, actually I don't
know if you've noticed,
but it is much bigger than the others.
You can even take, like, bacon Big Mac.
Even though it's supposed
to have two patties,
it is much bigger.
And then we have another
My Selection burger.
This one is called My BBQ.
This one has got barbecue sauce,
yes, I can see it,
Gouda cheese, and bacon,
and it's all topped off
with some balsamic vinegar.
It does still have the
same sort of fancy patty
that we had before.
Right, and after these very
nice and fancy burgers,
we have a gluten-free burger.
Oh. [record scratching]
Wait, why does it come in a bag?
Ooh. Yeah. Very -- ooh.
Yeah, not excited about this.
Just, I don't like the bread.
I'm sure you can find
better gluten-free bread.
There are so many around.
And if you want vegetables on your burger
for some strange reason,
you can get the Quarter
Pounder with cheese deluxe,
with lettuce and tomato and mayo.
Oh, did you see that squirt coming out?
Hit, like, a pocket of
mayonnaise on that one.
That's kind of weird.
It tastes great.
And if you just want to
go all in on the meat,
you can get a double
Quarter Pounder with bacon.
Look at this.
Right?
It's really good. Enough said.
And, surprise, another thing on our menu
you guys don't have: the McDouble.
McDonald's has a double cheeseburger,
which is double the
meat, double the cheese,
but also there's a McDouble on the menu.
What's the difference, you ask?
Well, McDouble only has
one slice of cheese.
As you can see from here, on top,
you got ketchup, mustard,
and pickles, no cheese.
The cheese is in between here.
I get it. Times are tough in this economy,
but get the extra slice
of cheese, guys. Come on.
I mean, we're not robots here.
We gotta have some pleasure in our lives,
and I think you should get
that extra slice of cheese.
Absorb the cost of it.
It's perfectly fine.
You're doing great. Come on!
Next one is another one
of those My Selection.
It's a chicken, avocado, and bacon burger.
Hm, it's got a different bun, this one.
Ooh, fancy.
All right, yeah, avocado is there.
There's, like, cabbage.
Mm, bit less excited about that.
And this one has
caciocavallo Silano cheese.
I don't know. We can call this --
you know sauce talk. The cheese talk.
Caciocavallo comes from the
same family of mozzarella.
They're called pasta filata cheeses,
and it's just basically the
way that you make cheese,
when you split the milk
into curds and whey.
It's made in a different way.
And you could say that caciocavallo
is like an aged mozzarella.
So it's a very versatile cheese
that I think is not
very well known abroad.
So, yeah, thank you, McDonald's,
for making that a thing
on your menu so everybody
can know about it.
So, here's the cheese that we
were talking about. [laughs]
It's just always a shame.
It's been put there with,
like, avocado and this cabbage.
Next one, we've got
double chicken barbecue.
After seeing all these big
ones, they do look quite small.
And then we have a chicken burger.
This one is different from a McChicken
because it has Caesar
sauce and no lettuce.
I think this is glue.
It looks like -- there is a type of glue
that looks exactly like that.
We also thought it'd be
fun to compare Happy Meals.
Here's the US one.
Open up this box, take a look around.
I'm pretty sure this is Pokémon.
This one comes with kid fries,
nuggets, which, we got a six-piece,
and this is their Pokémon toy.
So, they get the six-piece.
It's funny, like, a six-piece still seems
kind of like a lot for a kid.
Pokémon-themed toys
coming at you these days.
What is this?
OK, so we got Pikachu.
Does this have any value?
Because there's rare ones.
There's ones that have
a lot of value to them.
But not the ones at McDonald's, right?
Cyclizar? Any value?
We got Tandemaus.
Yeah.
And, of course, Sandaconda.
I'll go look on eBay after this
and see if these are worth anything.
Culturally, I have no idea what this is.
I don't know what -- this is a thing?
No, I have no idea who.
I don't remember any of those names.
Charlizard?
Cylizard?
Is this Cylizard?
Charmagarg.
OK.
In a Happy Meal in Italy,
you can find four items.
Obviously there is a drink,
then there is a main course
that could be either
nuggets [or] a hamburger.
And exclusive to Italy is a chicken burger
and a McToast, which is what we got today.
We're going to see that in a moment.
Then there is a side.
It can either be fries or baby carrots.
And a dessert.
This can be either fresh fruit, Actimel,
which is technically a drink
but it's a dessert here,
and Parmesan.
Here's our McToast. Nice.
The surprise of the day.
Yeah, they're just doing some
Hot Wheels collaboration.
So let's have a look at what is it.
I don't know, do you think
I can find a Vespa in here?
Oh, cute little skateboard,
pink one.
Nyoom.
We also have one exclusive
wrap option here in Italy.
It's a McWrap with crisp chicken breast
and Parmesan, or Parmigiano-Reggiano.
It's made in collaboration
with Giallozafferano,
which is the No. 1
recipe website in Italy.
To be honest, I think
they could have come up
with a better recipe, maybe, for the wrap.
The wrap does look very
sad, just the actual bread.
Chicken looks OK.
Italy clearly has plenty of exclusive
chicken-sandwich options, but
we have a few of our own here,
namely the McCrispy and the spicy McCrispy
and a deluxe version of each sandwich.
Let's take a look.
It looks closer to a chicken sandwich
you would find at a Chick-fil-A,
and then now Burger King has
the chicken king, I think?
McDonald's did all the
research that they do
to release this, the McCrispy sandwich.
Now, as you can tell,
it's just pickles on here.
A crispier, more natural-looking
piece of fried chicken,
and no sauce. Does it
always have no sauce?
I don't like that. I don't like
a place that gives you food
and, like, assembly requirements.
For the most part, I
should get the sandwich
the way it's supposed to be.
So this put your own sauce in it,
it's like, no, you put it on.
Here's the deluxe of it.
Yay, it has mayo. Whoa.
This to me is like,
yeah, do this every time.
This should just be the
sandwich. I don't ...
If you're like me and
you want to spice it up,
ah,
they have the spicy -- oh, come on.
There's spicy sauce on here somewhere.
Then, of course, they
got the spicy deluxe,
which of course has spicy sauce
and all those veggies in there.
So, yeah. McDonald's, still a contender
in the chicken-sandwich game, I feel.
Now we're on to the exclusive
sides here in Italy.
The first one that we got is cheesy fries.
The same fry, just with a
bit more bacon we got here.
Yeah, cheddar and bacon.
This is, like, I don't know,
a very sad Italian take on poutine.
On the menu next for sides,
we've got panzerotti.
So, actually very excited
about these because,
ooh,
panzerotti are from my hometown,
Bari, in the south of Italy.
The main difference is
that usually panzerotti,
the traditional ones, they are this big.
They're usually pretty wide.
It's, like, a main meal.
Panzerotti normally, they
have, tomatoes and mozzarella
is the most common filling,
but in Bari, again,
where they are from, you can
get them with ground beef,
mozzarella, and cooked ham.
These are actually my favorites.
I used to go and get them after school.
That's just, they are the perfect snack.
Quite good, actually.
Filling is OK, but I
think a real panzerotto,
when you bite into it,
basically all the filling
should almost come out.
It should, like, pop.
Like, the first reaction
when you eat a panzerotti,
this is like,
and then you sort of put your hand here
and just avoid a complete mess.
This brings us to the next snack,
which is Parmigiano-Reggiano, or Parmesan.
This is one of the most
counterfeit cheeses
in the world, so.
In Italy but also in Europe,
because of this whole protection thing,
anything that's called even
Parmesan, not the real name,
Parmigiano-Reggiano, is
in fact the real thing,
so at least we are safe on that side.
Having said that, I think
most of the Parmesan,
Parmigiano that you will
find around in supermarkets,
it's been aged for the bare minimum,
which is 12 months.
So it is good, it is the real thing,
but if you can choose,
just have something that's
been aged for a bit longer.
I think in Italy we do eat a lot of cheese
as a snack as it is, and I
do have definitely memories
of me coming back from school
and then just in the afternoon grabbing
some cheese off the fridge
and having a couple of slices
or even more than that.
I think my mom still does that,
so, sorry for exposing you, Mom.
Love it.
Over here we got another exclusive.
There are actually three
salads on the menu.
One is just a plain salad,
one is a salad with tomatoes,
and then we got one with crispy
chicken breast and Parmesan.
We could also select a dressing,
and we added olive oil.
You could also get a tiny
bottle of balsamic vinegar
or just vinegar.
We actually have no
exclusive sides in the US.
Every side option on our menu
can also be found in Italy.
I will say, though, I love that they have
a stick of cheese as a side,
kind of like a palate cleanser.
I would love that.
I would love to snack on cheese.
I love snacking on cheese.
We should have more cheese,
is what I'm trying to say.
We can bring it back with the sauces.
It's time for sauce talk, Italy edition.
La la la sauce talk!
That had to offend somebody.
Sauce talk.
We have several exclusive sauces
here in the United States,
including spicy Buffalo,
and then we have ranch, honey
mustard, sweet 'n' sour.
Now, I have two because one
is from the movie "Loki," apparently.
And of course you just get honey.
Of all these, I'd probably
go sweet 'n' sour,
but barbecue, which they
do have, is my favorite.
We have one exclusive sauce in Italy,
which is spicy mustard sauce.
Yeah.
Yeah, it is a bit spicy.
Not so much, though.
Doesn't numb your tongue.
I think actually it has a sweet
aftertaste for some reason.
For the early risers,
there are plenty of
exclusive breakfast items
at the US McDonald's,
and they're all savory.
Now, first thing I'm going to
talk about are the biscuits.
I'm not the person to
describe American biscuits
to the rest of the world.
They should have hired a poet.
This is the bacon, egg,
and cheese biscuit,
but you can get a biscuit version
of any meat or cheese
combination that you want.
In the middle here, though,
Italy, Claudia, everyone,
look at what I'm about to show you.
You know what pancakes are.
You know what syrup is.
You obviously know what
breakfast sandwiches are.
This right here is a McGriddle,
and they replaced the buns with this.
These bun pancakes.
This is a pancake, Italy. A pancake.
These, here. And they somehow
injected syrup in them,
so it's not like syrup like a sauce,
it's just, like, already syrup somehow,
and it is savory and
sweet at the same time.
It is so delicious.
It's a McGriddle. It's
fantastic. I love these.
This is a bacon, egg,
and cheese McGriddle,
but once again, you can get
it in any various sausage,
egg, and/or cheese
combination that you want.
McGriddles. Check 'em out.
I am the McGriddle No. 1 fan over here.
And the OG breakfast sandwich,
this is the egg McMuffin.
They got the Big Breakfast
with or without hotcakes.
I went with hotcakes.
You got eggs, bacon,
pancakes, English muffin,
this thing's fantastic.
And if you want to just
get hotcakes and sausage,
you can also do that.
And each order of pancakes
comes with our hotcakes syrup.
I think an unsung hero of the
McDonald's breakfast menu,
been a fan of this for years,
it is the sausage breakfast burrito.
Now, let's be honest.
Italy, in case you're wondering,
this in no way represents
an actual burrito.
I want to make that perfectly clear.
I would not put this in the same category
as any sort of burrito,
breakfast or otherwise,
but it's its own thing, and
I think it is fantastic.
It is in a flour tortilla.
Scrambled eggs, sausage, yes, I know,
peppers, cheese, and the secret weapon
is this, their Mexican-style salsa.
Again, there is nothing
authentically Mexican about this,
but it tastes great.
This was a go-to for years.
I could put away about four of these.
McDonald's also does offer oatmeal,
specifically fruit and maple oatmeal.
Moving on.
The Italian McDonald's
also sells breakfast items.
We've got ... [laughs]
That's super sad.
We got scrambled eggs with
bacon and a muffin and bread,
which does look more like a muffin.
And then we have a McMuffin
with bacon and egg.
Yeah, Italians don't really
have savory breakfast.
It's definitely a habit.
Like, you just associate
breakfast with sweet items.
All right, US also has their
own exclusive McCafé items.
Where'd they go?
The McDonald'ses near our studio
did not have the McCafé food items.
McDonald's in Italy has
really made an effort
with the McCafé menu items,
and there are really a lot
of items on the menu here.
So let's start from the croissants.
We've got quite a few on the menu.
I think this one here,
because you can see a little bit of brown,
this is the cocoa one with sourdough.
Pretty safe to eat.
This is the plain one.
Does look more like a
French-style croissant.
Nice layers in there as well, some air.
Over here, it's quite hard to tell,
but there is a subtle,
subtle layer of jam.
This is berries and cereal.
So, the dough, it's a little bit stiffer,
and, yeah, does smell a little bit
more like cereals.
Same amount of jam as in the others.
Not very generous, actually.
I think this one is the
last one that we got,
so it's the custard.
This looks like we have
a bit more in there.
Obviously, it's hard to tell
because the custard is the
same color as the dough,
has kind of turned the dough yellow.
Nice. Lots of lemon in there.
Another pastry option that you can get
is this cream braid.
This is quite a typical
thing as well in Italy.
Like, you do get these kind of pastries.
You can get them also savory
in different regions of Italy.
Let's see if they were
generous with the cream here.
Mm, yeah, I'll say so.
I prefer this cream.
In Italy, you can also get some cakes.
We have tiramisu, which is,
yeah, traditional Italian thing,
but not a breakfast item.
Like, I wouldn't really have
breakfast with tiramisu.
I know you guys want to hear
the opinion of an Italian,
so we're going to try this
tiramisu and see if it's proper.
Yes, quite good, actually.
We do have other cakes as well.
We have this one, which is
torta della nonna in Italian,
and that literally translates to
"grandma's cake" in English.
This one has lemon custard and pine nuts.
I think it's a bit of a joke
that this is actually
called grandma's cake
just because every Italian grandma
that's good in the kitchen
will be able to make something,
like, 100 times better than this.
We've got a strawberry cheesecake.
Let's move on to this
three-layer chocolate cake.
It's an absolute beast.
It's a bit too much.
I wouldn't have this for breakfast.
And then we have a few more items here
at the McCafé in Italy.
We have a marshmallow doughnut,
which looks like the most artificial thing
I've ever seen.
Then we've got a Nutella muffin.
It is true that Italians love Nutella,
and they eat it all the time.
Again, when I was a child,
my parents used to hide it.
Mm, sad. [laughs]
And the last item that
we've got is macarons.
We have chocolate macarons,
raspberry macarons,
and pistachios macarons,
or pistacchio, as we do say here.
Oh, the inside is, like,
dangerously green.
They don't taste so much
like pistachio, to be honest.
Desserts, McDonald's US,
we have these exclusives.
Starting down here, the baked apple pie.
The day they stopped frying these
is the day I stopped eating them.
Now they're pulling this with, like,
trying to make it look like
it's a homemade pastry.
It's not. This was just spit out
of an AI oven machine.
Blip, blip, blip. One a second. No human.
I'm the first human hand to touch this.
Also chocolate chip cookies.
They come in orders of
one, three, the trilogy,
or a tote of 13.
One good thing about the
McDonald's we went to today
is the McFlurry machine
was totally working,
and I got this one, the M&M's McFlurry.
We use the mini M&M's,
which are better than regular M&M's,
I don't know why, they just are.
Sundaes, sundaes, sundaes.
Maybe my favorite as a
kid, the caramel sundae.
Mm. Ooh, that's my childhood right there.
And you can get a fudge one as well.
For Italian exclusive desserts,
we have a pistachios McFlurry,
then a Baci Perugina McFlurry.
Baci Perugina are very popular chocolates.
They are made in Perugia, which
is in the center of Italy,
a town in the center.
And here we have a coffee sundae.
It's quite nice that they
actually gave us the espresso
so that we can make our own.
A bit like an affogato, in a way.
The other sundaes are caramel, berries,
another Baci Perugina again,
and the fior di latte,
which is basically the
Italian version of vanilla.
Ooh.
Nice, yeah.
Now on to the cold drink
options, starting down here,
all the soda options
you get here in the US.
Of course, we have way more than Italy.
Starting with Dr Pepper.
Oh, OK there.
So fantastic.
Diet Coke. No.
Ugh.
This completely unnatural-looking thing
is Hi-C Orange Lavaburst.
It's not carbonated,
but it's also not juice.
I can't explain it. It's Hi-C.
You can also get a sweet tea
and an unsweetened iced tea at McDonald's.
What I did feel like getting was this,
the frozen Fanta blue raspberry.
Oh, God, it's so sweet and so syrupy.
Don't drink this, don't
give it to children,
don't have it ever.
They also have a Coke
version, frozen Coke.
Also don't bother.
Lemonade, though.
So, we found out that lemonade in America
is the least different
from lemonade in the UK.
Again, this is not carbonated,
it's not really juice,
it's something different.
I don't know what
lemonade is like in Italy.
Oh, man, it's so tart and so good.
On to coffee drinks,
or should I say cold coffee drinks,
from here to here.
I understand that's not a thing in Italy,
which I think is hilarious.
This giant glass right
here is iced coffee.
You can also get it caramel flavored
or French vanilla flavored.
I went with black, the
ace of spades right here.
Mm.
Oh, man, they do something
with their coffee there.
They do something where it
tastes like it's really roasted.
I mean, I'm sure it's not.
You can also get a iced latte.
This over here is a frappé.
You can get a mocha frappé
or a caramel frappé.
Basically if you're an adult
and you want a milkshake,
you get a frap.
You can also get smoothies at McDonald's.
We have a mango pineapple smoothie
and a strawberry banana smoothie.
In Italy, we have a few exclusive drinks.
Let's start with the cold options.
We have Lipton iced tea
both in lemon and peach.
Then we have some fruit juices.
We have pear,
ace, which is very popular here in Italy.
It should be very orange.
It's a mix of orange, carrots, and lemon.
Yeah, very orange.
And it's named ace, which is A-C-E,
after the three vitamins
that these fruits,
or vegetables, I guess,
these carrots, contains.
And then we got peach fruit juice.
And here are our McDonald's
hot coffee drinks.
"Coffee," right, Italy?
All right, we get it.
We went a little overboard
with our coffee drinks
here in America, and McDonald's,
of course, is no different.
You can get a caramel macchiato,
a caramel cappuccino.
Why are we doing so much
caramel stuff in America, right?
Ah, caramel latte.
You can also get it in vanilla.
Don't.
You can also get a mocha latte.
We have a premium roast coffee.
As I said before, I don't
know what they're doing
at McDonald's, but
I like the coffee.
But you can also get,
finally, a black hot tea.
What is this? The UK?
Ugh.
The hot drinks exclusive to Italy
are obviously the king
of hot drinks, espresso.
Then we've got a Moroccan coffee,
which is not Moroccan in the sense of
it's not Moroccan-style
coffee, but weirdly enough,
and to be honest, I never
really understood this,
it's named after a type
of Moroccan leather
that looks this color.
Honestly, it's like an
espresso with some milk.
And then we got ginseng
coffee and barley coffee,
which technically shouldn't
really be called coffee
because it contains no
coffee, it has just barley,
and this is like an alternative for people
that cannot drink coffee
and they still want to have something
like a little espresso after lunch.
Yeah, it smells very cereally.
I don't know. I'm not a big fan.
And then we got just a
standard latte macchiato.
This is the closest thing
you will get to a latte
that you will find here in Italy,
so it's just a lot of
milk with a bit of coffee
and some foam at the top.
In Italy, a Big Mac will cost
you 6 euros and 10 cents.
In dollars, that's about $6.76.
A Big Mac in the US will cost you $6.29.
That's a 3% price increase
from Italy to the US.
What if you turn that into a combo meal?
In Italy, a small Big Mac
meal with medium fries
and a medium drink will
cost you 8 euros 90,
and that's $9.86.
Does a combo meal make
a difference in the US?
A medium Big Mac combo meal over here
will cost you $11.42.
You can also save some
money if you buy in bulk.
Here in Italy, you can
get a two-person Mac menu,
which includes two Big Macs,
two large portions of fries,
two large Coca-Colas, six nuggets,
for 18 euros.
In the US, we only do Big Mac combo meals,
as mentioned before.
So in order to get the
same order in Italy,
you would have to order two Big Mac meals
plus six nuggets on the side.
It would cost around $36, which
in Italy is about 33 euros.
Price-wise, I think they
are definitely better value
than other fast-food chains.
Well, not to believe Five Guys,
I know that one has a reputation
for being quite expensive,
but I think the burger
is, like, half the price.
For the panzerotti, I think
that was more than 3 euros,
3 euros something, which, honestly,
for, like, three of those as a
side, it is a little bit sad.
But again, I grew up in
the town of panzerotti,
and I used to have, like,
a full one this size
for, like, 2 euros. That was 15 years ago,
so maybe now it would
translate into something
like maybe 5 or 6.
Once upon a time, McDonald's
was the cheaper option.
It was a lot of food
for not a lot of money.
As many people probably
pointed out on social media,
this food is no longer
inexpensive. It's not expensive.
Maybe because of the competition,
maybe because of inflation,
probably because of corporate greed,
McDonald's and most fast food, I find,
is not a good value anymore.
Let's compare some items to see
what the nutrition is of McDonald's food.
A sandwich that exists in both countries
and is theoretically
identical is the Big Mac.
In the US, a Big Mac
contains 590 calories,
34 grams of total fat, 46 grams of carbs,
and 9 grams of sugar.
How about an Italian Big Mac?
One of those here contains 509 calories.
Of these, there are 26 grams of total fat,
42 grams of carbs, of
which 9 grams are sugars,
and then there are 920
milligrams of sodium.
What if we made it a combo meal?
Starting with the fries,
a medium fry in the US
contains 320 calories,
15 grams of total fat,
43 grams of carbs, no sugar,
and 260 milligrams of sodium.
While a medium fries in
Italy contains 330 calories,
16 grams of total fat, 41 grams of carbs,
of which 0.4 grams are sugars,
and 212 milligrams of sodium.
And let's add the medium
Coke into the mix.
It contains 210 calories, no fat,
56 carbs, 56 of those are sugar,
and 55 milligrams of sodium.
That's funny there's salt in the soda.
We'll do the same here.
Here's what's inside a
medium Coke in Italy.
It's 168 calories,
zero grams of fat,
42 grams of carbs, 42 grams of sugar,
so it's all sugar,
and zero grams of sodium.
That leaves the total for
the Italian meal at this:
1,007 calories,
42 grams of fat,
125 grams of carbs,
51.4 grams of sugars,
and 1,132 milligrams of sodium.
While in the US, the total
ends up looking like this.
Let's talk about ingredients now.
McDonald's Italy shares a
lot of information, actually,
about its ingredients.
That's because the majority
of the items on the menu
are made with 100% Italian products.
The beef, like the one
that's used in the Big Mac,
is sourced from over
15,000 different farms
located in northern Italy
around the regions of
Lombardy, where we are now,
the capital of which is Milan,
and Piedmont.
There are apples from South Tyrol,
which is where speck is made,
just on the border with Austria.
And just to give some recognition
to the southern regions,
because I'm from there,
so no bias at all, we've got some apricots
from the Vesuvio National
Park, so in Campania,
and Sicilian oranges.
And when we talk about
DOP, this red label here,
it's what you are looking for.
It's a label that's used for
a lot of traditional products
around the EU, and that means
that they have to be made
following certain specific standards,
most of the time in a very artisanal way.
That also means that certain
products like Parmesan
cannot be made outside of a specific area.
That has to do with the climate.
So, for example, for cheese,
the main argument is that
it's a raw-milk cheese,
and in raw-milk cheeses, you
do taste what the cows eat.
So obviously, the grass
has a different taste
depending on where you are in the world.
But we do have some
American-sourced ingredients
for McDonald's.
The potatoes used for our
fries are grown in Washington
at 100 Circles Farm,
which is owned by Bill Gates, apparently.
They grow the potatoes in circles so big
you can see it from space.
The potatoes are then cut into
fries at 70 miles per hour,
which is faster than a cheetah.
That's the unit of measurement?
That not-so-secret ingredient
to McDonald's fries
is beef flavoring, which they've
been doing since the 1950s.
You want to see if there's
any differences in the US
and Italy's Big Mac?
These are all the ingredients
in a Big Mac in the US.
Altogether, that's 68 ingredients
that make up a Big Mac.
That's a lot.
28 of those ingredients are in the bun,
which is quite a lot for bread.
The Big Mac sauce also
has a lot of ingredients,
26 altogether, and it seems like we added
a lot of relish to ours, which
bulks out the ingredients.
In Italy, there are 54
ingredients in a Big Mac.
Here they are.
We only have 20 ingredients
in the bun, actually,
because we don't fortify the
flour like you do in the US.
Our Big Mac sauce has 15 ingredients,
which is still nine less
than the US Big Mac, Joe.
Most of the other ingredients are similar,
but we don't have as many colorings
or thickeners as you do in the US.
Some of the ingredients
listed in our US Big Mac sauce
caught our attention, so we
want to explain what they are.
First up, propylene glycol alginate
is derived from brown seaweed
and is a thickener used in foods
to give a smooth natural texture.
Next up we got hydrolyzed corn,
which is a plant protein
from corn or maize
and is used as a flavoring
for its umami taste.
Sodium citrate helps cheese to
melt without becoming greasy.
I did grow up with McDonald's.
I definitely celebrated a
couple birthdays over there.
I had my share of Happy Meals
with lots of little girly toys.
It is definitely considered healthier
than other fast-food chains
because it has been around
for quite some time,
but also, obviously,
because it has Italianized
a lot over the years,
incorporating things like Parmesan
or like traditional cheeses and cold cuts.
So just appealing a little bit more
to the taste of Italians.
I have been to stores
in the US and the UK,
and Italian McDonald's seem, I don't know,
a little bit fancier.
It's everywhere and made burgers and fries
and sodas to go the most
popular meal in the country,
and then how many places followed suit?
With Burger King and
Wendy's and all the like.
And now we got
chicken-sandwich-version ones,
we got fried chicken.
McDonald's McDonald's-ified
the entire country
and the world.
McDonald's is like Nike or Christianity.
It's everywhere!